Programming Throwdown, Episode 186, becoming a manager. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. This is last programming throwdown of the year. Pretty wild. I got a plastic welding kit a while back, and I actually, okay, so check this out.
Programming Throwdown，第186期，成为一名管理者。Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好。这是今年最后一期 Programming Throwdown。真是太疯狂了。我前阵子买了一个塑料焊接工具，其实，好吧，来看看这个。
So I had about three days alone. So we talked about this a little bit before the show. So my wife and her mom and the kids all went to Dallas. And so I was in Austin myself. I did a ton of cleaning up around the house and getting things in order and all that. And one of the things I did is I 3D printed a thing to hold the keys. So it's just imagine it's just like a little A frame. And on the top of the A frame, there's hooks that come down and you put the keys on that.
我有大约三天的时间是一个人待着的。我们在节目开始前稍微聊过这个。我妻子、她妈妈和孩子们都去了达拉斯。所以我一个人在奥斯汀。我把家里打扫得干干净净，把东西整理得井井有条。我做的一件事就是用 3D 打印了一个挂钥匙的东西。想象一下，它就像一个小小的 A 型框架。在 A 型框架的顶部，有向下延伸的钩子，你可以把钥匙挂在上面。
It's pretty simple. But it came in in several. parts. And you're supposed to like friction fit it together, but my 3D printer is like not that great. And so, you know, it didn't, it didn't fit that tightly. And so I was like, oh, yeah, I don't want to throw this out because it's pretty big. Let me just see if I can sort of heat it up, because I've heard of people doing this, heating the plastic and then it just melts and then you melt it, you weld it, right? You melt the two pieces of plastic together. And then when you stick them together, they're sort of like chemically joined or whatever.
很简单。但它是由几个部分组成的。本来应该通过摩擦力把它拼在一起，但我的 3D 打印机不太好。所以，你知道，它装得没那么紧。我就想，哦，对了，我不想把它扔掉，因为它挺大的。让我看看能不能把它加热一下，因为我听说有人这么做，加热塑料，然后它就会融化，接着你把它焊接起来，对吧？你把两块塑料融在一起。然后当你把它们粘在一起时，它们就像是化学结合了，或者类似的情况。
I'm probably not saying this right. So I pulled out this plastic welding kit. And it's basically like a gun, kind of like a glue gun. And when you press it, it's just the end, it gets super, super hot. So in that sense, it's like kind of like a soldering iron. It's like really powerful. I feel like it's way more powerful than a soldering iron, but I could be wrong about that. And the end effector is like this flat plate.
我可能说得不太对。所以我拿出了这个塑料焊接工具。它基本上就像一把枪，有点像热熔胶枪。当你按下它时，末端会变得非常非常热。从这个意义上说，它有点像烙铁。它感觉比烙铁强力得多，但我可能说错了。它的末端是一个扁平的板。
So you can kind of rest that. and it just heats that area up. And so I was able to do kind of like a side-to-side motion over the gap. First, I clamped the parts together, right? I did like a little side-to-side motion over the gap, and it melted it. It totally melted it. I didn't do a good enough job that you can't see the seat. So, you know, I definitely...
所以你可以把它放在那里，它会加热那个区域。我能够沿着缝隙做一种左右移动的动作。首先，我把零件夹在一起，对吧？我在缝隙上做了一点左右移动的动作，它就融化了。它完全融化了。我做得不够好，以至于你还能看到接缝。所以，你知道，我绝对……
Also, probably this would work a lot better if it was 100% infill. You know, in this case, it's not, and, you know, the grain doesn't line up, right? etc. But the important thing is like structurally it works. I wouldn't throw it on the ground or anything, but like it held everything together and that part was kind of cool. So it also, the kit I bought comes with pieces of metal and you're supposed to push on the metal. Think of it as like a staple. Oh. But it's like a W shape. And you push on the staple. And because, you know, metal transfers heat so well, the whole staple gets super hot, and then the whole staple kind of melts into the plastic. And so now you have a piece of metal kind of holding it together.
另外，如果填充率是 100%，效果可能会好得多。你知道，在这种情况下，它不是，而且，你知道，纹理对不齐，等等。但重要的是，从结构上讲它是有用的。我不会把它扔在地上什么的，但它确实把所有东西都固定住了，那部分还挺酷的。而且，我买的工具包里还带有一些金属片，你应该把金属片压进去。把它想象成订书钉。哦。但它是 W 形的。你把订书钉压进去。因为，你知道，金属导热性很好，整个订书钉会变得非常热，然后整个订书钉就会融化进塑料里。所以现在你有一块金属把它固定在一起了。
I didn't try that because I wanted to, you know, just my first time using it, but maybe I'll do that next. But the thing I took away from it is like, yeah, plastic welding is pretty easy, and the kit was very cheap on Amazon. So it's pretty cool. I mean, if you ever have a broken piece of plastic I actually have a piano key from a keyboard that we have that has plastic keys. I'm thinking about welding that together now that I've kind of got my feet under me. I have many thoughts. We didn't talk about this before, so I have so many thoughts. Okay, I'll try to be brief.
我没试过那个，因为我想，你知道，这只是我第一次使用它，也许下次我会试试。但我从中得到的结论是，是的，塑料焊接相当容易，而且这个工具包在亚马逊上非常便宜。所以这很酷。我的意思是，如果你有一个坏掉的塑料件，我其实有一个钢琴键，来自我们家的一台塑料琴键的键盘。我现在正考虑把它焊起来，因为我已经上手了。我有很多想法。我们之前没聊过这个，所以我有很多想法。好吧，我会尽量简短。
I have never used what you're describing sounds a lot like a soldering iron, but we've come to the same conclusion, something similar. We have, my children have those 3D printing pens that you just hold and they, are exactly like a 3D printer without the motion. So you just click a button and it squirts out hot plastic. So it's kind of like a hot glue gun, except it's temperature controlled for PLA or ABS. And so we'll use that.
我从没用过你描述的那个东西，听起来很像烙铁，但我们得出了相同的结论，类似的东西。我们有，我的孩子们有那种 3D 打印笔，你拿着它，它们就像没有运动机构的 3D 打印机。所以你只需按下一个按钮，它就会喷出热塑料。所以它有点像热熔胶枪，只不过它是针对 PLA 或 ABS 进行温度控制的。所以我们会用那个。
And a very similar, you can just use the tip to iron, but you can also like squirt plastic and then use that because it melts into it and is, I guess actually like welding is or soldering. Yeah. Where you're melting a similar metal. The other thing is,
而且非常相似，你可以直接用笔尖来熨烫，但你也可以像喷射塑料一样使用它，因为它会融化进去，而且，我想实际上就像焊接或烙铁一样。是的。你在熔化类似的金属。另一件事是，
you said like solid info, but you can do more outer walls or lower walls or upper walls depending on the orientation when we've done this, we've found that. So you get a thicker shell basically so you don't accidentally cut into the hollow interior.
你说过像实心填充，但你可以根据方向做更多的外壁、下壁或上壁，当我们这样做时，我们发现。所以你基本上得到了一个更厚的外壳，这样你就不会不小心切入中空的内部。
If you're using PLA, there is like a glue solvent, but it's really nasty. I wouldn't recommend it. But other things like ABS and others can be stuck together with a solvent and actually like, weld, but then you can also buy super glue with an accelerant. If you don't know super glue,
如果你使用的是 PLA，有一种胶水溶剂，但它真的很恶心。我不推荐它。但其他材料如 ABS 等可以用溶剂粘在一起，实际上就像焊接一样，但你也可以买带有促进剂的强力胶。如果你不知道强力胶，
when you put it on, normally takes like kind of a while to harden, but you can spritz like an accelerant, which is some sort of catalyst and causes it to rapidly harden. And it does weaken it, but only like a trivial amount. So that can also work really well. You think super glue would be better than plastic welding? I don't. It depends. It probably wouldn't matter, right? If you have two flat surfaces that are reasonably large. I mean, super glue is going to be amazing. But if you have like, depending, right,
当你涂上它时，通常需要一段时间才能变硬，但你可以喷一点促进剂，这是一种催化剂，会导致它迅速变硬。它确实会削弱它，但只是微不足道的一点点。所以这也可以工作得很好。你觉得强力胶会比塑料焊接更好吗？我不觉得。这取决于情况。可能没关系，对吧？如果你有两个相当大的平坦表面。我的意思是，强力胶会很棒。但如果你有，取决于情况，对吧，
like if it's, if they meet narrowly or something, it could be difficult to kind of get enough super glue or super glue in there. Right. But the last thing is, and I was thinking about this a little, right now we're recording it. It's still close to the Thanksgiving holiday.
比如如果它们接触得很窄或者其他什么，可能很难获得足够的强力胶或者把强力胶弄进去。对吧。但最后一件事，我刚才在想这个，我们现在正在录音。离感恩节假期还很近。
So stuff's on sale, but it goes on stuff like regularly. But I'm assuming about earlier today, the like current generation of 3D printers is really good. and reasonably cheap, like $200, $300 for not to show, but like bamboo lab. So if you have a printer that isn't really good, like definitely consider like the A1 or A1 mini, they're very cheap. And if you're using like personal thing, it's a huge step up from like the Ender 3 style of like, if you're using something like that and you haven't moved to a sort of
所以东西在打折，但它经常打折。但我假设今天早些时候，当前这一代 3D 打印机真的很好，而且相当便宜，比如 200 到 300 美元，不是为了展示，而是像 Bambu Lab。所以如果你有一台不太好的打印机，绝对可以考虑像 A1 或 A1 mini，它们非常便宜。如果你是在个人使用，这比 Ender 3 风格的机器有了巨大的进步，如果你正在使用类似的东西，而且还没有转向某种
next generation one, definitely consider if it's something that you do. I know 200, 300, still kind of a lot of money. But, you know, we have that newer class in it. The software is better. If you're really, really into open source, look for an open source one. But if you're sort of more flexible on sort of what you're doing, the bamboo labs are pretty like just plug and play.
下一代产品，如果这是你经常做的事情，一定要考虑一下。我知道 200、300 美元仍然是一笔不小的钱。但是，你知道，我们有了更新的类别。软件也更好了。如果你真的非常喜欢开源，那就找一个开源的。但如果你在做什么方面比较灵活，Bambu Labs 基本上就是即插即用的。
They have an app and you can literally, it's been game changing for my kids. They just go in the app and select what they want and it just prints it. And they don't have to go to a computer and slice it. You still can, but you don't have to. and so they are much more into 3D printing than they would have been otherwise because they can browse the app and just send it to the to the printer. So okay, I have a lot of other thoughts, but I'll just stop there.
他们有一个应用程序，你真的可以，这对我的孩子们来说是改变游戏规则的。他们只需进入应用程序并选择他们想要的东西，它就会打印出来。他们不必去电脑上切片。你仍然可以这样做，但你不必这样做。所以他们比以前更喜欢 3D 打印了，因为他们可以浏览应用程序并直接发送到打印机。所以好吧，我还有很多其他想法，但我先说到这里。
But yeah, I mean, call to action, you know, if you have a broken piece of plastic, you could try this out. It actually works surprisingly well. Sodering iron, plastic glue, hot glue, fix your stuff. That's right. Yeah, we build everything. We code up everything, even destruction. Time for the news.
但是的，我的意思是，行动号召，你知道，如果你有一个坏掉的塑料件，你可以试试这个。它实际上出奇地好用。烙铁、塑料胶、热熔胶，修好你的东西。没错。是的，我们构建一切。我们编写一切代码，甚至是破坏。新闻时间到了。
All right. Okay, I have the first news. Parse.bought, turn any website into an API. This is like a bunch of people are doing this. Browser use, which is another company, has a thing called Skills that does this. But this is pretty interesting. I mean, the idea is they crawl a website.
好的。好的，我有第一条新闻。Parse.bot，将任何网站变成 API。这就像很多人都在做这件事。Browser use，这是另一家公司，有一个叫 Skills 的东西可以做到这一点。但这很有趣。我的意思是，这个想法是他们抓取一个网站。
And you're kind of counting on them, I guess, to crawl it really well and click on every single button and everything. But assuming that they do that, once they've crawled it, then they keep kind of breadcrumbs. It's like, oh, for me to look at your bank balance, probably terrible example. Ooh. You have to. Okay. For me to check your Starbucks gift balance.
你有点指望他们，我想，能很好地抓取它并点击每一个按钮和所有东西。但假设他们做到了，一旦他们抓取了它，他们就会留下某种面包屑。就像，哦，为了让我查看你的银行余额，这可能是一个糟糕的例子。噢。你必须。好的。为了让我查看你的星巴克礼品卡余额。
There you go. You have to log in. And so, you know, here's like a recipe. Like the first time, I guess it's like using. like a bunch of really heavy AI. It's like, here's a screenshot. What do I do? The AI thinks for a while, right?
给你。你必须登录。所以，你知道，这里有一个配方。第一次，我想这就像使用一大堆非常强大的 AI。就像，这是一张截图。我该怎么做？AI 会思考一会儿，对吧？
But then it kind of like leaves breadcrumbs. And so once it's sort of logged in, then it's like, okay, these are things the AI typed. Next time, you know, we could just type them. Now, of course, you have the website changes. You're busted. So you have to, you know, there's basically like,
但随后它会留下一些面包屑。所以一旦它登录了，它就会说，好的，这些是 AI 输入的内容。下次，你知道，我们可以直接输入它们。当然，现在网站变了。你就完蛋了。所以你必须，你知道，基本上就像，
think of it as like a cache, caching system. like I cashed the flow to log into Starbucks. Now if Starbucks changes the website, that's kind of like a cash miss. And so you're going to have to go back to the AI and the AI is going to take a long time. But Starbucks probably doesn't change your website that often. And so hopefully you get a lot of cash hits. And so when it works, it's like super magical.
把它想象成一个缓存，缓存系统。比如我缓存了登录星巴克的流程。现在如果星巴克更改了网站，那就像是一个缓存未命中。所以你必须回到 AI 那里，AI 会花费很长时间。但星巴克可能不会经常更改他们的网站。所以希望你能得到很多缓存命中。所以当它工作时，它就像超级神奇。
It's like it just boom like you're logged into Starbucks, you know, in like a few minutes or something or even less than that. like maybe 30 seconds. But yeah, I think this is really cool. You know, the web, kind of like email, it's not going away. I don't think chatGBT is going to delete the internet or anything like that. The internet's going to be here for, you know, as long as as email has been around, which is decades and decades. So having AI that can, like, interact with the web seems super powerful.
就像它砰的一声，你登录了星巴克，你知道，在几分钟内或者更短的时间内。比如可能 30 秒。但是的，我觉得这真的很酷。你知道，网络，有点像电子邮件，它不会消失。我不认为 ChatGPT 会删除互联网之类的。互联网会一直存在，你知道，只要电子邮件存在，那就是几十年又几十年。所以拥有一个可以与网络交互的 AI 看起来超级强大。
Yeah, I think that I, Yeah, I'm curious how that ends up working. There's a lot of stuff for anti-scraping. I mean, a lot of stuff is, you know, not maintain it. I'm curious how well it handles, you know, stuff that, I guess, like people don't want you to scrape. And so they do various things to try to detect or evade that or, you know, mitigate it, I guess. Yeah, yeah.
是的，我想，是的，我很好奇它最终会如何运作。有很多反抓取的东西。我的意思是，很多东西，你知道，没有维护。我很好奇它处理那些，我想，人们不希望你抓取的东西的效果如何。所以他们会做各种各样的事情来试图检测或规避它，或者，我想，减轻它。是的，是的。
I mean, it's like all the problems of scraping and then now other problems. So it's definitely not. a trivial task, which is, I think, one of the reasons why it's so interesting. My guess, so admittedly, I haven't tried any of these. I have tried browser use and Skyvern and a bunch of these tools that browse the web with AI, and it is kind of how I described initially, where it's like AI pauses, takes a screenshot, looks at all the HTML, thinks for a while, and then clicks. And then the whole thing repeats. And those actually surprisingly work terribly. You would think with all the time to think and the screenshots and everything that it would work well. But there's just so many things
我的意思是，这就像抓取的所有问题，然后现在又有了其他问题。所以这绝对不是一个简单的任务，我认为这就是它如此有趣的原因之一。我的猜测是，诚然，我没有尝试过这些。我尝试过 Browser use 和 Skyvern 以及一堆这些用 AI 浏览网络的工具，它确实就像我最初描述的那样，AI 暂停，截屏，查看所有 HTML，思考一会儿，然后点击。然后整个过程重复。而那些实际上出奇地糟糕。你会认为有这么多时间思考和截图，它应该工作得很好。但有太多的事情
that don't work well. Like for example, you know, when you look at the HTML, you see all the things that you can't actually click on. Except, oh, but you can, because if you use like Java, you can click. Yeah, when the mouse is in this hitbox, it dynamically changed. Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
工作得不好。例如，你知道，当你查看 HTML 时，你会看到所有你实际上无法点击的东西。除了，哦，但你可以，因为如果你使用像 Java，你可以点击。是的，当鼠标在点击框中时，它会动态改变。是的。是的，完全正确。
So, like, for example, a website might have a pop-up, and they're expecting you to, like, answer some questions. But you could write JavaScript to click a button behind the pop-up.
所以，例如，一个网站可能会有一个弹出窗口，他们期望你回答一些问题。但你可以编写 JavaScript 来点击弹出窗口后面的按钮。
And unless the website defends against that, it'll let you make that click. And you can even browse the site behind the pop-up. But what happens is now, the website's really confused. And so I've seen like major websites, like just crash because
除非网站对此进行防御，否则它会让你进行点击。你甚至可以浏览弹出窗口后面的网站。但现在发生的情况是，网站非常困惑。所以我见过像大型网站，直接崩溃，因为
you're doing things that the developers didn't really expect. So I've tried a lot of these programs and my conclusion is that it's a super hard problem. Now we just added this other layer of breadcrumbs and all of that. But these kind of problems are also the most
你在做开发人员没有预料到的事情。所以我尝试过很多这些程序，我的结论是这是一个超级困难的问题。现在我们刚刚添加了面包屑和所有这些东西的另一层。但这些类型的问题也是最
interesting and lucrative if you can pull it off. So I think it's a space to keep an eye on for sure. Yeah, putting aside privacy for a minute and getting a little off topic from what you're saying, but I'll try to make it brief, is I think the sort of like AI powered web browser and the sort of middle term, short term could be a really cool thing. And I don't think I've seen a good implementation of it yet, but things like you're saying, like here's my bank, my bank doesn't offer a good API. Like searching at a bank is terrible. for transactions. I know I made this or whatever. And so I want to log in so that I'm owning the
有趣和有利可图的，如果你能做到的话。所以我认为这是一个绝对值得关注的领域。是的，暂时把隐私放在一边，偏离你所说的话题，但我会尽量简短，我认为这种 AI 驱动的网络浏览器在短期内可能是一件非常酷的事情。我不认为我还没见过好的实现，但就像你说的，比如这是我的银行，我的银行不提供好的 API。比如在银行搜索交易太糟糕了。我知道我做了这个或那个。所以我想要登录，这样我就拥有了
credentials and I don't have to give them. But then I want you to like browse around and answer, like go through all the pages and just interact like a human would temporarily. And like, answer questions for me or hey, you know, I'm trying to find coupon codes for this website. And like, can you go find coupon codes and try plugging them in and see if any of them are active or not, you know? And email search as an example, still sucks horribly. So like, something that could like, you know, not have to integrate with every single email provider, but just be like, hey, this is my inbox. Go through my inbox and find this thing. Like, super, super useful. You know, I think there's tons of optimizations. Long term, hopefully we just ask
凭据，我不必给他们。但我想要你浏览一下并回答，比如浏览所有页面，就像人类一样暂时交互。比如，为我回答问题，或者嘿，你知道，我正在为这个网站寻找优惠券代码。比如，你能去找到优惠券代码并尝试输入它们，看看是否有任何一个是有效的吗，你知道？电子邮件搜索作为一个例子，仍然烂透了。所以，像那种可以，你知道，不必与每个电子邮件提供商集成，而只是说，嘿，这是我的收件箱。浏览我的收件箱并找到这个东西。比如，超级超级有用。你知道，我认为有很多优化。长期来看，希望我们只是问
and it happens. But midterm before all those magic integrations, I, it does seem like this sort of adaptation layer, but I can't imagine building a business in this space. Like, I just don't feel it's defensible. I don't feel like it's going to last long term, but props to people trying to kind of eke out a living doing that. Yeah, it's kind of, yeah, you're kind of, interesting. I think if you, if you wait four or five years, all the big players will have something. And so you have kind of like like building a company around something like that is kind of like breaking into a a bank or something. It's like, okay, you know, I have 60 seconds. So like, you know, get this company off the ground and get some kind of traction and get escape velocity. And then,
然后它就发生了。但在所有那些神奇的集成之前的短期内，它确实看起来像这种适配层，但我无法想象在这个领域建立一家企业。就像，我只是不觉得它是可防御的。我不觉得它能长期持续，但向那些试图通过这样做来谋生的人致敬。是的，这有点，是的，你有点，有趣。我想如果你等四五年，所有的大玩家都会有类似的东西。所以你有点像围绕这样的东西建立一家公司，就像闯入一家银行之类的。就像，好的，你知道，我有 60 秒。所以，你知道，让这家公司起步并获得某种牵引力并获得逃逸速度。然后，
and then maybe you can take the money or take the user base and pivot it to doing something totally different. Speaking of AI companies, my next news topic is the recent release of Google's LLM Gemini 3. I guess it's more than elements, multimod. I don't know what they classify their AI. We'll just use that term, I guess. And there's a couple of really interesting things about Gemini. Of course, seems to have moved to state of the art forward. Benchmarks are just terrible in AI right now.
然后也许你可以拿钱或利用用户群并将其转向做完全不同的事情。说到 AI 公司，我的下一个新闻主题是谷歌 LLM Gemini 3 的发布。我想它不仅仅是元素，多模态。我不知道他们如何分类他们的 AI。我想我们还是用那个术语吧。关于 Gemini 有几件非常有趣的事情。当然，似乎已经将最先进的技术向前推进了。基准测试在 AI 领域现在简直太糟糕了。
It's just so subjective. Like, it's very difficult. Lots of the benchmarks say they did better, but everyone's not really sure. Is it meaningful? Like, it doesn't change the space. I think it's, in my mind, how far we've come in just a couple of years, but now like the turning test is just like nobody thinks it means anything anymore. I'm not a big like,
这太主观了。就像，这非常困难。很多基准测试说他们做得更好，但每个人都不太确定。这有意义吗？就像，它没有改变这个领域。我认为，在我看来，我们在短短几年内走了多远，但现在图灵测试就像没人觉得它有什么意义了。我不是一个大的，
but it just seems these chatbots are like so good now that a lot of stuff that they were doing really bad a couple years ago, they don't do anymore, but yet it still hasn't like made the world stop turning. And so aside from that, though, it does seem like a big improvement. I don't think it's been formally announced, but the sort of speculation on the internet seems to be
但这似乎这些聊天机器人现在太好了，以至于很多几年前他们做得非常糟糕的事情，他们现在不做了，但它仍然没有让世界停止转动。所以除此之外，它确实看起来是一个很大的进步。我不认为它已经正式宣布，但互联网上的猜测似乎是
that they did training and, and they have been doing inference, but now both on their TPU hardware, as opposed to GP. Yeah, that's right. Which makes a really big shift. I didn't see any like concrete confirmations that this is true, but people seem pretty sure that this is what's happening.
他们进行了训练，并且一直在进行推理，但现在都在他们的 TPU 硬件上，而不是 GPU。是的，没错。这确实是一个很大的转变。我没有看到任何具体的确认这是真的，但人们似乎非常确定这就是正在发生的事情。
Of course, Nvidia has been, you know, a big story for a while. Lots of people would love to sort of break in into that space. But I think also TPU's tensor processing units as different than GPUs, graphics processing units, although I don't know how applicable that name is anymore, but are much more, in theory, power efficient or could be. So for edge sort of compute
当然，英伟达已经，你知道，很长一段时间以来一直是一个大故事。很多人都想进入那个领域。但我认为 TPU 张量处理单元与 GPU 图形处理单元不同，尽管我不知道那个名字现在还有多适用，但从理论上讲，它们更节能，或者可能是。所以对于边缘计算，
robotics, that kind of stuff, it would be really cool to sort of unlock this. In my mind, I'm excited, but no one seems to be definitely pressing against it where we have things that aren't just static, but actually training and inferencing and sort of adapting themselves. and rolling forward. So the things are learning, I can have, you know, something on my edge device that is improving itself, learning my habits, and not just like in a sort of out of band kind of way, but in a sort of like ingesting new data and updating and sort of refreshing as opposed to the sort of release of new checkpoints that is kind of what happens today. And so definitely a leap forward, lots of cool stuff happening in this space, lots of competition. Also really interesting,
机器人技术，那种东西，解锁这个会非常酷。在我看来，我很兴奋，但似乎没有人真正地在推动它，我们拥有的东西不仅仅是静态的，而是实际上在训练和推理并适应自己。并向前推进。所以这些东西在学习，我可以有，你知道，在我的边缘设备上有一些东西在自我改进，学习我的习惯，不仅仅是以一种带外的方式，而是以一种摄取新数据并更新和刷新的方式，而不是今天发生的那种发布新检查点的方式。所以绝对是一个飞跃，这个领域发生了很多很酷的事情，有很多竞争。也非常有趣，
we were talking just the previous, you know, about companies and having, you know, rob the bank. But it's funny how dynamic the situation is with top players still. So deep seek and, you know, meta, Google, open AI, anthropic. Like, like, it seems to be still a very open playing field for, you know, all of these providers. And no one seems to be carving out a specific niche yet. And they seem to just all be kind of generally competing. So lots of speculation about how that that's going to develop. Yeah, yeah, that makes sense. I think that the challenge, you know, tying a lot of what you said together is that
我们刚才谈到了公司和拥有，你知道，抢劫银行。但动态情况与顶级玩家仍然存在，这很有趣。所以 DeepSeek 和，你知道，Meta，谷歌，OpenAI，Anthropic。就像，对于所有这些提供商来说，这似乎仍然是一个非常开放的竞争环境。而且似乎没有人专门开辟出一个特定的利基市场。而且他们似乎都只是在普遍竞争。所以关于它将如何发展有很多猜测。是的，是的，这很有道理。我认为挑战在于，将你所说的大部分内容联系在一起，是
we haven't seen a lot of what I call value capture. I'm not sure if I'm using that word correctly, but basically, so, okay, look at like search engines. So, you know, there was Alta Vista, there was Ask Jeeves, right? There were all these different search engines, but they didn't really capture a lot of value. and there were attempts to say like, oh, if you, um, uh, if you pay a certain amount,
我们没有看到很多我称之为价值捕获的东西。我不确定我是否正确使用了这个词，但基本上，所以，好的，看看像搜索引擎。所以，你知道，有 Alta Vista，有 Ask Jeeves，对吧？有所有这些不同的搜索引擎，但它们并没有真正捕获很多价值。而且有人试图说，比如，哦，如果你，嗯，呃，如果你支付一定的金额，
then you can be kind of in like a, a certain tier or like there's a certain section that was premium and that didn't really take off. And then Google really captured value by just saying, like anyone can pay to be at the top of any search result. And here's sort of like a mechanism for doing that. Um, and then Google captured, you know,
那么你就可以处于某种层级，或者有一个特定的部分是高级的，但这并没有真正流行起来。然后谷歌通过说，任何人都可以付费出现在任何搜索结果的顶部，真正捕获了价值。这里有一种实现这一点的机制。嗯，然后谷歌捕获了，你知道，
a ton of value in the continuation. used to do that. And so for AI, it's like, there's a lot of, yeah, as you said, the Turing test is totally blown out. I mean, this is a little embarrassing, but my dad thought that META.I. was an employee. It's like, you know, I talked to META.I. I was having problems with my account, and they couldn't really help me, but they were so nice, I talked to them for like 15. So the Turing test, especially for, you know, older folks, is totally solved, right? I mean, younger folks could get more and more savvy, of course. But, you know, Turing test totally blown out.
在延续中捕获了大量价值。过去是这样做的。所以对于 AI 来说，就像，有很多，是的，正如你所说，图灵测试完全被打破了。我的意思是，这有点尴尬，但我爸爸认为 META.AI 是一名员工。就像，你知道，我和 META.AI 谈过。我的账户出了问题，他们无法真正帮助我，但他们太好了，我和他们谈了大约 15 分钟。所以图灵测试，特别是对于，你知道，老年人来说，完全解决了，对吧？我的意思是，年轻人当然会越来越精明。但是，你知道，图灵测试完全被打破了。
But, you know, that's a good example. You know, like did META create any value there out of that 15-minute conversation? No, right. So, you know, there's customer support representatives, representatives. that's Sierra and a bunch of companies are doing that. That might be the first place where they're capturing significant value, although even there it's a cost savings versus like in the case of Google, they created a new market.
但是，你知道，这是一个很好的例子。你知道，META 从那 15 分钟的对话中创造了任何价值吗？没有，对吧。所以，你知道，有客户支持代表，代表。那是 Sierra 和一堆公司正在做的事情。那可能是他们捕获重大价值的第一个地方，尽管即使在那里，与谷歌的情况相比，它也是一种成本节约，谷歌创造了一个新市场。
So cost savings is okay, but real value captures when you create a new market. Like, for example, a robot that can mow your lawn and do your laundry. with one robot or something like that. Now it's like, okay, there's a whole new market that you just opened up. And so until I think AI captures value, it's going to be really hard to benchmark and this is, I guess, gets into the whole AI bubble.
所以成本节约还可以，但真正的价值捕获是在你创造一个新市场的时候。比如，一个可以割草和洗衣服的机器人。用一个机器人或者类似的东西。现在就像，好的，有一个全新的市场你刚刚打开。所以直到我认为 AI 捕获价值，它将非常难以进行基准测试，这，我想，进入了整个 AI 泡沫。
You know, can AI capture value rapidly and a large of magnitude to escape all of the debt that it's accumulated? Nobody really knows yet. But, but, yeah, Gemini 3, from a technical standpoint, Gemini 3 is very impressive. I don't have access yet, so I'm only going based off what I've read. The internet reviews. Yeah, exactly.
你知道，AI 能否迅速捕获价值并达到足以逃避它所积累的所有债务的量级？没人真正知道。但是，但是，是的，Gemini 3，从技术角度来看，Gemini 3 非常令人印象深刻。我还没有访问权限，所以我只是根据我读到的内容。互联网评论。是的，完全正确。
Rotten Tomatoes gives it 97%. Have you tried the image one part of it, though, nanobanana? I have. I've done a lot with nano banana. I know banana is very good. Very fun. Yeah, folks out there try. these things if you haven't tried them yet. They are super
烂番茄给了它 97%。不过你试过它的图像部分了吗，Nano Banana？我试过。我对 Nano Banana 做过很多。我知道 Banana 非常好。非常有趣。是的，外面的朋友们，如果你们还没试过这些东西，就试试吧。它们超级
fun. Okay, my second news topic is Dept Anything 3. So there's a bunch of these anything models and computer vision. So the most famous is arguably a segment anything model. And what Sam does,
有趣。好的，我的第二个新闻主题是 Depth Anything 3。所以有很多这些 Anything 模型和计算机视觉。所以最著名的是可以说是 Segment Anything Model。而 Sam 所做的，
and there's now Sam 2, you give it a picture, no training, nothing. Like first you download the model. The model's enormous, right? But then you give it a picture and it segments the picture for you. So for example, let's say you are working in a factory and you have a bunch of photos of a conveyor belt and different things moving along the conveyor belt. You know, you could like
现在有了 Sam 2，你给它一张图片，没有训练，什么都没有。就像你先下载模型。模型非常巨大，对吧？但随后你给它一张图片，它就为你分割图片。所以例如，假设你在工厂工作，你有一堆传送带的照片和沿着传送带移动的不同东西。你知道，你可以像
start doing background subtraction and all sorts of computer vision stuff if you know what you're doing. Or you could just run Sam and Sam will segment out the conveyor belt and the object, which is one line of Python, which is pretty remarkable. So, of course, is not perfect, but it's pretty darn good, considering it wasn't trained on
开始做背景减除和各种计算机视觉的东西，如果你知道你在做什么的话。或者你可以直接运行 Sam，Sam 会分割出传送带和物体，这只需要一行 Python 代码，这非常了不起。所以，当然，它并不完美，但考虑到它没有在
your use case or anything. I've used it for a bunch of different things. It's very impressive. So, going along with that trend, we now have depth anything. So you can give it a picture of anything,
你的用例或任何东西上进行训练，它已经相当不错了。我已经把它用于各种不同的事情。它非常令人印象深刻。所以，顺应这一趋势，我们现在有了 Depth Anything。所以你可以给它任何东西的图片，
and it will generate a depth map. So for each pixel, it will tell you roughly the distance those photons had to travel to go from whatever it is you're looking at to, you know, that lens or your eyeball or whatever it is. So, so for example, if you run this on a picture of a tennis ball, you can imagine like this sort of radial image where the parts on the edge of the tennis ball are the furthest away, and then part of the tennis ball that's in the center is going to be the close. assist to your eyeball, right? So depth anything. And I just think these anything models are just
它会生成一个深度图。所以对于每个像素，它会告诉你光子从你看到的任何东西传播到，你知道，那个镜头或你的眼球或任何东西所必须经过的大致距离。所以，所以例如，如果你在网球的照片上运行这个，你可以想象这种径向图像，网球边缘的部分是最远的，然后网球中心的部分将是离你的眼球最近的，对吧？所以 Depth Anything。我只是觉得这些 Anything 模型只是
super interesting. I mean, again, it's like it feels like there's just so much value you can capture there once you have the ability to just get a depth estimate from pretty, pretty while. Yes, I've been looking at this for a project I'm wanting to work on where I don't ask it. Anyways, having like two web cameras and stitching them together. And I thought it would be really easy to like stitch into basically like a wider field of view with an arbitrary number of cameras. Like I assumed this is like a solved problem. Like open CV would just have something. Yeah.
超级有趣。我的意思是，再一次，感觉一旦你有能力从相当，相当狂野的地方获得深度估计，你就可以捕获很多价值。是的，我一直在为一个我想做的项目寻找这个，我没有问它。无论如何，拥有两个网络摄像头并将它们缝合在一起。我以为将它们缝合在一起基本上就像一个具有任意数量摄像头的更宽视野会非常容易。就像我假设这是一个已解决的问题。就像 OpenCV 应该会有一些东西。是的。
So it turns out like digging into it, like just some pay software you can. But basically you can kind of like understand the transforms between them. You can kind of do some of it. But basically, and I didn't really think about it, one of the problems, unless you have a very, very carefully set up system, is understanding the distance away of the various objects. So like an Insta 360 or something where it's like very well controlled the positioning, but just setting up something in an arbitrary arrangement and then having them stitch.
所以结果证明，深入研究它，就像一些付费软件你可以。但基本上你可以像理解它们之间的变换一样。你可以做其中的一部分。但基本上，我并没有真正考虑它，问题之一，除非你有一个非常、非常仔细设置的系统，否则就是理解各种物体的距离。所以像 Insta 360 之类的东西，它的定位控制得非常好，但只是在任意排列中设置一些东西，然后让它们缝合。
Everything's at different distances and you end up with parallax. And so I kind of got into thinking about how you would integrate something like one of these depth, anything to understand the depth estimates, do the stitch, and then maybe you would not be able to run it in real time. So maybe you would run it like every so often and like sort of update in the background, the depth. And so it wouldn't be exactly perfect for, you know, moving objects,
一切都在不同的距离，你最终会得到视差。所以我开始思考如何集成像这些 Depth Anything 之一的东西来理解深度估计，进行缝合，然后也许你无法实时运行它。所以也许你会每隔一段时间运行它，比如在后台更新深度。所以它对于，你知道，移动物体来说不会完全完美，
but for static objects, it would be okay. So it definitely very powerful though, because, you know, whatever, just a year ago, a few years ago,
但对于静态物体，它会没问题。所以它绝对非常强大，因为，你知道，无论如何，就在一年前，几年前，
it would have been incredibly difficult to like, I have an image. How do I like produce a depth map that, you know, isn't just atroach, because they were not very good. They were very like flat plane before based on sort of a segmentation. And so these new ones are much, much more impressive. Yeah, that makes sense. I mean, you're trying to calculate like the 3D transformation of each of these cameras.
要像，我有一张图片，这会非常困难。我如何生成一个深度图，你知道，不仅仅是垃圾，因为它们不是很好。它们在基于某种分割之前非常像平坦平面。所以这些新的要令人印象深刻得多。是的，这很有道理。我的意思是，你正在尝试计算这些摄像头的每一个 3D 变换。
And so you could do that at a low rate and then just use the most recent transformation. If there were infinite time, I would have done this as a project over the last week. but unfortunately, I only got as far as understanding where their problem was and having an idea of what I would build. So speaking about projects, I finally got around to, though. I know we've talked about on the podcast before RunPod,
所以你可以以低速率执行此操作，然后只使用最近的变换。如果有无限的时间，我会在过去一周内把它作为一个项目来做。但不幸的是，我只进展到理解他们的问题所在并有了我想构建什么的构思。所以说到项目，我终于有时间了，虽然。我知道我们之前在播客上谈论过 RunPod，
but I finally said I had not tried any of the AI video generation tools, and I wanted to not just like pay for them. I was not even pay for it. I didn't want, I'm cheap, I didn't really want to pay for it. And I wanted to kind of learn it myself. And so my kids had a picture that they wanted to like add an animation to. In this case, it happened to be they were, they were with an animal and they wanted the animal to do something funny, like something hilarious and you interact with them.
但我终于说我还没有尝试过任何 AI 视频生成工具，我想不仅仅是为它们付费。我甚至不想付费。我不想，我很吝啬，我真的不想付钱。我想自己学习它。所以我的孩子们有一张他们想要添加动画的图片。在这种情况下，碰巧是他们，他们和一只动物在一起，他们想要动物做一些有趣的事情，比如一些搞笑的事情，你和它们互动。
But it was just a static picture. And of course, nothing actually happened. They just were, you know, like at a zoo, just standing next to the animal. But we wanted to animate because we see these videos on the internet. And so I said, I'm going to finally figure this out because I should. I should know how to do this. and went through the process of using WAN 2.2. I don't know that's particularly relevant,
但这只是一张静态图片。当然，什么也没发生。他们只是，你知道，在动物园，只是站在动物旁边。但我们想要制作动画，因为我们在互联网上看到了这些视频。所以我说，我终于要弄清楚这一点，因为我应该。我应该知道怎么做。并经历了使用 WAN 2.2 的过程。我不知道这是否特别相关，
but finding a template, finding the way to get it to auto download on RunPod. And I was assuming I was going to have to sort of give it my credit card and risk it. But actually, I was pleasantly surprised. Shout out to them, unlike, you know, AWS or something else.
但找到一个模板，找到让它在 RunPod 上自动下载的方法。我以为我必须，你知道，给它我的信用卡并冒险。但实际上，我感到惊喜。向他们致敬，不像，你知道，AWS 或其他什么。
You basically buy, in this case, I buy, I think the minimum, like $25 of credits worth of runtime. And if you're careful to select a GPS, you that is not like super state of the art. It's very reasonable. So I think in total I've made, you know, four or five, five second videos. And I think I spent like two or three dollars of my
你基本上购买，在这种情况下，我购买，我想是最低的，比如 25 美元的运行时间积分。如果你小心选择 GPS，你不是那种超级先进的。它非常合理。所以我认为总共我制作了，你知道，四五个，五秒钟的视频。我想我花了大约两三美元的我的
credits for like bringing up, downloading all of the stuff. And if you were to generate a bunch while the session is up, it would be way cheaper. But I don't because I like do it. I like, I'm going to figure out. So I take it back down. So I'm not using time. But if you're careful with it and you're interested in these things and you're like me and you don't have a like modern GPU that can run any of this stuff locally, by the way, which is really expensive. Yeah. Definitely check out RunPod, but also check out some of these like bigger models. I've run locally like stable diffusion type models before, but the video generation just doesn't work very well. But if that's been holding you back, definitely check this out. And it is very interesting to learn how to use like comfy UI,
积分用于启动，下载所有东西。如果你在会话期间生成一堆，它会便宜得多。但我没有，因为我喜欢做它。我喜欢，我要弄清楚。所以我把它关掉。所以我没有使用时间。但如果你小心使用它，并且你对这些事情感兴趣，并且你像我一样，没有一台可以本地运行所有这些东西的现代 GPU，顺便说一句，这非常昂贵。是的。一定要看看 RunPod，但也看看一些这些更大的模型。我之前在本地运行过稳定扩散类型的模型，但视频生成效果不太好。但如果这一直阻碍着你，一定要看看这个。学习如何使用像 Comfy UI 这样的东西非常有趣，
how to like kind of do all of this stuff that you kind of, at least for me you see in YouTube videos or people, how are they doing this? My family likes to watch these like Christmas videos with music on the TV in the background, but it's obvious they're all AI generated because people do weird stuff in the background. I was like walking around to like a Christmas market and a kid is like flinching between like, you know, wearing a jacket and wearing a coat and wearing. It's like anyways,
如何像，你知道，做所有这些你，至少对我来说，你在 YouTube 视频中看到的东西，或者人们，他们是怎么做到的？我的家人喜欢在电视背景中观看这些带有音乐的圣诞视频，但很明显它们都是 AI 生成的，因为人们在背景中做奇怪的事情。我就像在逛圣诞市场，一个孩子就像在穿夹克和穿外套之间畏缩。这就像无论如何，
people are out there doing this and turning it into like, like money, which I'm not interested in. But I feel a little left behind that I haven't been making funny AI videos for my family. So I have this thing where I want to go back and take like pictures of my older relatives or even people have passed away, sort of just making kind of that Harry Potter style like subtle movement, you know, animation for some of these and sort of like providing that as like a, not only a gift into the family, you know, or like funny moments, you know, here's a picture of my father at the Thanksgiving table and the turkey, you know, blows up or something.
人们在外面做这件事并把它变成，就像，钱，我不感兴趣。但我感到有点落后，因为我还没有为我的家人制作有趣的 AI 视频。所以我有一件事，我想回去拍一些我年长亲戚的照片，甚至是已经去世的人的照片，只是制作那种哈利波特风格的微妙运动，你知道，动画，并将其作为一种，不仅是给家人的礼物，你知道，或者像有趣的时刻，你知道，这是我父亲在感恩节餐桌上的照片，火鸡，你知道，爆炸了之类的。
And then, you know, people will get a laugh out of it. It's very cheap humor, but I'm here for it. So I'm trying to figure this out. This is my quest. This is, you came to the right place, Patrick. Because I have been doing this for a while. Oh, my gosh. And the website I use is phall.a.i, which stands for features and labels.
然后，你知道，人们会从中得到笑声。这是非常廉价的幽默，但我支持它。所以我正在尝试弄清楚这一点。这是我的追求。这是，你来对地方了，Patrick。因为我已经做了一段时间了。哦，我的天哪。我使用的网站是 phall.a.i，代表特征和标签。
Dot AI. And they have, like, warmed up all the models for you. No. And so you just charge, you're charged per call. And so for, like, image to video. your charge maybe $0.25 or $0.25 or something for call. And so the most recent one, there's two. So my wife's pretty paranoid about the kid's safety.
Dot AI。他们有，就像，为你预热了所有模型。不。所以你只需按调用收费。所以对于，比如，图像到视频。你每次调用可能收费 0.25 美元或 0.25 美元。所以最近的一个，有两个。所以我的妻子对孩子的安全非常偏执。
I mean, this is like very common, right? And so I take the kids on these hikes, and sometimes she gets nervous. And I'll send pictures. So I set her this picture of the kids standing over this rock ledge and underneath is a creek and there's actually a um there was a uh what's it called a it's a black snake a water moccasin there's a water moccas in the creek now now like it's like maybe a 10 foot drop off this rock so like you know the water moxen is not coming up to us or anything like that we're just sitting there on the rock uh it's a giant boulder you know eating sandwiches and watching nature watching water moccasins or
我的意思是，这就像非常普遍，对吧？所以我带孩子们去这些徒步旅行，有时她会紧张。我会发送照片。所以我发给她这张孩子们站在岩石壁上的照片，下面是一条小溪，实际上有一个，嗯，有一个，呃，它叫什么，它是一条黑蛇，一条水莫卡辛蛇，小溪里有一条水莫卡辛蛇，现在，就像，它离这块岩石可能有 10 英尺高，所以，你知道，水莫卡辛蛇不会上来找我们之类的，我们只是坐在岩石上，呃，这是一块巨大的巨石，你知道，吃三明治，看大自然，看水莫卡辛蛇或者
whatever i said this picture and my wife gets really nervous. And I was like, I was like, oh, check this out. So I sent a video where basically the water vacancy leaps out of the water turns into like a dragon and eats all of us. And I was like, oh, I guess you're right the whole time. The other one I did was, there's a model called Biggs Boson which is kind of like the CERN particle thing
无论我说什么，这张照片都会让我妻子感到非常紧张。我就说，嘿，看看这个。于是我发了一个视频，视频里水怪从水里跳出来，变成了一条龙，把我们所有人都吃了。我就说，哦，看来你一直都是对的。我做的另一个是，有一个叫 Biggs Boson 的模型，有点像欧洲核子研究中心（CERN）的粒子实验。
but it's a voice cloning model totally open source and that one is because it's just audio you can run it on a reasonable GPU or even on a CPU and so I cloned some celebrities' voices and I had them wish
但它是一个完全开源的语音克隆模型，因为它是纯音频的，你可以在普通的 GPU 甚至 CPU 上运行它，所以我克隆了一些名人的声音，让他们祝
a happy birthday to some friends of mine and I purposely picked celebrities that I know my friends hate. Oh. And it's like, hey, I know you're a big fan. So good. So good.
我的一些朋友生日快乐，我特意挑选了我朋友讨厌的名人。哦。就像是，嘿，我知道你是他的超级粉丝。太棒了。太棒了。
And, you know, it's everyone I sent it to, I knew that they would find it funny. So, yeah, I didn't send it to anybody who would be genuinely offended. I saved, I saved that for my family. But for these people, and they thought it was absolutely just dropped hilarious. They were asking me, you know, how I made it. They want to make it for their parents,
而且，你知道，我发给的每个人，我都知道他们会觉得这很有趣。所以，是的，我没有发给任何会真正感到被冒犯的人。我把那个留给了我的家人。但对于这些人，他们觉得这简直太搞笑了。他们问我，你知道，我是怎么做的。他们想为他们的父母做这个，
for their friends, all that stuff. Yeah, I think the SORA video generation from Open AI seems to, I start to see some videos of these getting posted that seem pretty cool. But I don't know. The way that they want to scan your face as like the entry fee into, like, allowing you access to that always kind of creeps me out. So I haven't done, I haven't done it. Same. Yeah, exactly. Same. I mean, The ones on foul, they're open source. They're decent. They're not great.
为他们的朋友，所有这些。是的，我觉得 OpenAI 的 SORA 视频生成看起来，我开始看到一些这类视频被发布出来，看起来很酷。但我不知道。他们想要扫描你的脸作为进入门槛，以此让你获得访问权限的方式总是让我感到毛骨悚然。所以我还没做，我还没做。我也是。是的，完全一样。我也是。我的意思是，那些开源的，它们还不错。虽然算不上特别好。
They're definitely not soar quality, but they're decent. I mean, for a laugh, they're good enough. Perfect. That's all I need. All right. My book of the show isn't even a book. It is a video, but it's a documentary, so I'm going to call it sort of cerebral, and therefore, my book of the show, which is the thinking game, which came out recently on YouTube.
它们绝对达不到 Sora 的质量，但还算不错。我的意思是，为了图一乐，它们足够了。完美。这就是我所需要的。好了。我的本期推荐书目甚至不是一本书。它是一个视频，但它是一部纪录片，所以我打算称它为某种脑力激荡，因此，我的本期推荐是《思维游戏》（The Thinking Game），最近在 YouTube 上发布。
And is sort of a deep mind documentary and a little bit. behind sort of sort of their story and it's getting a lot of really good reviews. Something that if you haven't heard about, definitely worth checking out. I think it is very sort of, I used to say, apropos, like very of the moment. I think it's like an hour and a half sort of long, but, you know, one of those sort of well-shot sort of documentaries going to the story of a lot of history there, which is crazy to think they've been at it for a while, but just the progress, like even, which, now we're back to the side, but even this video generation, like, I saw someone regenerating Will Smith eating spaghetti,
它算是 DeepMind 的一部纪录片，稍微有点幕后故事，而且评价非常好。如果你还没听说过，绝对值得一看。我觉得它非常，我过去常说，恰如其分，非常符合当下。我觉得它大概有一个半小时长，但是，你知道，那种制作精良的纪录片，讲述了很多历史，想到他们已经坚持了这么久真是疯狂，但仅仅是进步，就像，现在我们又回到了这个话题，但即使是这种视频生成，就像，我看到有人重新生成了威尔·史密斯吃意大利面的视频，
which I know we've talked about. And it was like, oh, that was like 10 years ago. Like, nope, nope, that was like two and a half years ago or something. It's like, we've gone from that to, you know, or something like that. I mean, now it's like flawless. I mean, now if you ask for that video, you just get it. And it's like, you have to squint really hard to find the different. Yeah. So two years ago, the YouTube video, was AI Will Smith eating spaghetti. Yeah, spaghetti. So, yeah, anyways, this is crazy.
我知道我们讨论过。当时觉得，哦，那是 10 年前的事了。不，不，那大概是两年半前的事。就像，我们已经从那时发展到，你知道，诸如此类。我的意思是，现在它简直完美无瑕。我的意思是，现在如果你要求那个视频，你就能得到它。而且，你必须眯着眼睛非常努力才能找到区别。是的。所以两年前，那个 YouTube 视频是 AI 威尔·史密斯吃意大利面。是的，意大利面。所以，是的，总之，这太疯狂了。
And the deep mind folks, you know, AlphaGo was like an early headline that was like 10 years ago, a little less than 10 years ago. So I mean, crazy, crazy how far, you know, this stuff came sort of. But of course, people have been at it for a lot longer, really thinking about it, really working hard on it. So definitely something worth checking out. Not like sort of super deeply technical, but sometimes it's okay. Sometimes it's good to see sort of like an artistic view of the stuff that we all maybe take a little bit for granted.
还有 DeepMind 的那些人，你知道，AlphaGo 是早期的头条新闻，那大概是 10 年前，不到 10 年前。所以我的意思是，疯狂，疯狂，这东西发展得如此之快。但当然，人们已经研究了很长时间，真的在思考它，真的在努力研究它。所以绝对值得一看。不像那种超级深奥的技术，但有时候没关系。有时候看看我们大家都可能有点习以为常的东西的艺术视角是件好事。
Yeah, totally. My book of this show is a classic. It's Plato, the Republic. This is like a bunch of volumes. It's a large tomb. But I found it super interesting. I don't know if we've, I think we've probably talked about this. But, but, you know, one of the things that that they focus, I mean, it's a bit.
是的，完全同意。我本期的推荐书目是一部经典之作。它是柏拉图的《理想国》。这是一套书，是一部大部头。但我发现它超级有趣。我不知道我们是否，我想我们可能讨论过这个。但是，但是，你知道，他们关注的一件事，我的意思是，它有点。
massive book, but one of the things they focus on is, you know, have you, you've probably heard this thought experiment, Patrick, so let's say somebody loans you, uh, their gun. You borrow their gun because you're going hunting or something. Okay. And then, you know, you kind of forget that you borrowed it. They come back months later and they're in a rage, you know, and they're maybe intoxicated. They're intoxicated, they're super mad, and they're like, I'm so mad, I need to take out Bill. Bill's going to get it. I need my gun back. So, you know, like, it's his possession.
厚重的书，但他们关注的一件事是，你知道，你，你可能听说过这个思想实验，帕特里克，假设有人借给你，呃，他们的枪。你借了他们的枪，因为你要去打猎什么的。好的。然后，你知道，你有点忘了你借了它。他们几个月后回来，处于愤怒状态，你知道，他们可能喝醉了。他们喝醉了，他们超级生气，他们说，我太生气了，我需要干掉比尔。比尔要倒霉了。我需要拿回我的枪。所以，你知道，就像，这是他的财产。
And so if you don't give it back or you lie and you say you don't have it or you threw it away or something, you're kind of stealing. You're doing something immoral, right? But if you give it back, that person is going to go on some rampage. And so it's bad for the world, right? And so, you know, Plato and Socrates and there's this other person who plays the person on the other end of the debate, but he always loses. Basically, Plato wins every time, right? So there's this poor guy. I forgot his name.
所以如果你不还给他，或者你撒谎说你没有，或者你把它扔了什么的，你就是在偷窃。你在做一些不道德的事情，对吧？但如果你还给他，那个人就会去大开杀戒。所以这对世界来说很糟糕，对吧？所以，你知道，柏拉图和苏格拉底，还有另一个人在辩论的另一端，但他总是输。基本上，柏拉图每次都赢，对吧？所以有这个可怜的家伙。我忘了他的名字。
Terrible with names, but he, you know, he's just kind of a stooge, you know, but, you know, he says, well, you know, yeah, you have to return it because it's his property and you're stealing it if you don't do that. And then Plato says, well, but, you know, it's for the greater good for you not to do it. And the conclusion, after, like, all this debate they come to is, is that there's really no absolute laws. You know, everything kind of has a caveat. And, you know, there's, what what you should do instead is try to come up with, like, proper values. So, like, you value life. So if you know this person is going to go on some rampage, then the lives. are worth the not telling this person the truth or whatever so it gets it gets but it's just like such an interesting question and uh i'm sure if there's like a philosophy major out there they are just like completely like you know tearing their hair out right now as i try to explain this but um i'm actually going through uh um instead of just reading it because i feel like i am just it's kind of like it's almost to read a reinforcement learning research paper in Europe's next month or something. It's like there's so much background, right? So instead of
我不擅长记名字，但他，你知道，他只是个傀儡，你知道，但是，你知道，他说，好吧，你知道，是的，你必须归还它，因为那是他的财产，如果你不这样做，你就是在偷窃。然后柏拉图说，嗯，但是，你知道，为了更大的利益，你不应该这样做。结论是，在经过所有这些辩论后，他们得出的结论是，真的没有绝对的法律。你知道，每件事都有一个警告。而且，你知道，你应该做的是尝试提出，比如，正确的价值观。所以，比如，你珍视生命。所以如果你知道这个人会去大开杀戒，那么生命就值得你不告诉这个人真相或者其他什么，所以它变得，但这是一个非常有趣的问题，而且，我敢肯定，如果外面有哲学专业的学生，他们现在肯定完全像是在抓狂，因为我试图解释这一点，但是，嗯，我实际上正在经历，呃，嗯，而不是仅仅阅读它，因为我觉得我只是，这有点像，几乎就像在下个月的 NeurIPS 上阅读强化学习研究论文一样。就像有很多背景知识，对吧？所以与其
doing that where I knew I wouldn't really get a lot out of it, I paid for this basically class where this person who, you know, has a master's degree in like literature and philosophy kind of reads it and then kind of like an audible, but audible plus plus, right? So this person reads it, then they stop and then there's a discussion and then they read the next section and so you know a lot of people like I don't know if a lot of people do is but I
那样做，因为我知道我不会真正从中得到很多东西，我付钱参加了这个课程，这个课程里有一个拥有文学和哲学硕士学位的人，他会阅读它，然后有点像有声读物，但比 Audible Plus Plus 更好，对吧？所以这个人阅读它，然后他们停下来，然后进行讨论，然后他们阅读下一部分，所以你知道很多人，我不知道是否很多人这样做，但我
used to often get the urge to like read the classics you know it's like oh I've I've I've tried to have a good example here I mean a lot of the classics are pretty relatively easy to read like Moby Dick is not that hard to read or whatever but like the Republic's an example
过去经常有冲动去读经典，你知道，就像，哦，我，我，我试着在这里举个好例子，我的意思是很多经典作品相对容易阅读，比如《白鲸记》读起来并不难，或者其他什么，但像《理想国》就是一个例子。
you know the divine comedy you know these books that are just like there's so much knowledge you need to have, especially about the era and the times and all of that, to really understand them that it's just not tractable for people like us. This is like a great way to read those books and understand them. So I'm about, I think, halfway through.
你知道《神曲》，你知道这些书，就像你需要有很多知识，特别是关于那个时代和背景的知识，才能真正理解它们，这对我们这样的人来说是不可行的。这是一种阅读这些书并理解它们的好方法。所以我大概，我想，读了一半了。
They're also skipping some volumes, because I guess some volumes are just so specific to that era that they couldn't really get enough value out of them. you know, without like, again, without, if you study enough, you could do anything, but they, they know their audience. So they're like, we're going to read volume one and then we're going to skip to volume three, et cetera, et cetera. But I've been having a blast and I recommend folks try that. Yeah, I can say I've ever read any of the hard to read classics and never done a philosophy. So I won't say much because I too feel there's a whole thing where people like to play at understanding
他们还跳过了一些卷，因为我想有些卷对那个时代来说太具体了，他们无法从中获得足够的价值。你知道，没有，再说一次，没有，如果你学习得足够多，你可以做任何事情，但他们，他们了解他们的受众。所以他们说，我们要读第一卷，然后我们要跳到第三卷，等等，等等。但我一直玩得很开心，我建议大家尝试一下。是的，我可以说我读过任何难读的经典，也从未学过哲学。所以我不会多说什么，因为我也觉得有一整套东西，人们喜欢假装理解
it. And then, like, I do respect that there is a whole field of stuff. there and I know nothing about it. Yeah, I feel like I know a little bit more than I did. But, you know. So Patrick, I'm not giving your gun back. That's basically what were there?
它。然后，就像，我确实尊重那里有一个完整的领域，而我对此一无所知。是的，我觉得我比以前知道的多一点。但是，你知道。所以帕特里克，我不会还你的枪。这就是我们讨论的重点吗？
Well, I okay, I take offense that I'm on. Okay, anyways, we're just moving on. My tool of the show is a game. It is, I thought for sure I must have talked about it before, but I haven't, which is core keeper. Corekeeper is a 2D
好吧，我，好吧，我被冒犯了，因为我在上面。好吧，无论如何，我们继续。我的本期工具是一个游戏。它是，我原以为我肯定以前谈论过它，但我没有，那就是《Core Keeper》。《Core Keeper》是一个 2D
top-down game in this sort of style of Minecraft or Terraria, where you kind of mine blocks in a subterranean environment and you are interacting with creatures and, you know, fighting, what do you call, mobs, I guess, is the Minecraft term. And kind of going around and automating some stuff and, you know, gardening and doing, I guess it's like a life simulator meets some I don't know. I never got into the Sims, but definitely have enjoyed Terraria and Minecraft, and this is sort of in that same vein,
自上而下的游戏，类似于《我的世界》或《泰拉瑞亚》的风格，你在地下环境中挖掘方块，与生物互动，你知道，战斗，你叫什么，怪物，我想，这是《我的世界》的术语。并且四处走动，自动化一些东西，你知道，园艺，做，我想这就像一个生活模拟器遇到了某种，我不知道。我从来没有玩过《模拟人生》，但绝对喜欢《泰拉瑞亚》和《我的世界》，这有点属于同一类，
which is CoreKeeper. It's available. I don't think it's on mobile, but it's on PC, Switch, Xbox, PlayStation, so lots of places. It's not a new release by any means, but if you haven't noticed yet,
那就是《Core Keeper》。它可用。我不认为它在手机上，但它在 PC、Switch、Xbox、PlayStation 上，所以有很多地方。它绝不是什么新发布的游戏，但如果你还没注意到，
I'm way behind on playing, like, new games, but I've been playing this one and enjoying it. And for those folks who remember from last episode, I am proud to say, I finally launched a rocket in Factoria. I forced myself to sit down and do it. And then I had the inclination to keep going.
我在玩新游戏方面落后很多，但我一直在玩这个，并且很享受。对于上一集还记得的那些朋友，我很自豪地说，我终于在《异星工厂》（Factoria）里发射了一枚火箭。我强迫自己坐下来完成它。然后我有继续下去的倾向。
And I was like, nope, I am stopping and I've got to switch. So now I've been playing Corkkeeper, play some other games. Is it co-op or are you playing by yourself or both? So I think the kind of default mode is played by yourself, but there is a co-op mode as well. There unfortunately isn't a split screen, which would have been amazing. But yeah, I think it's sort of between,
我就说，不，我要停下来，我必须切换。所以现在我一直在玩《Core Keeper》，玩其他一些游戏。它是合作模式还是你一个人玩，或者两者都有？所以我认为默认模式是自己玩，但也有合作模式。遗憾的是没有分屏，那会很棒。但是是的，我认为它介于，
between systems co-op can take place, which would be super cool, just not something that's feasible with my setup and my family. So it would have been awesome if it was a split screen, but whatever, left wanting there. But definitely still a good game.
系统之间的合作可以进行，那会非常酷，只是在我的设置和我的家庭中不可行。所以如果它是分屏的话会很棒，但无论如何，还是有所欠缺。但绝对仍然是一个好游戏。
It should be relatively cheap because, like I said, it's been out for kind of a long time. Very cool. My tool of show is also a game. It's workers and resources, Soviet Republic. Oh, dear.
它应该相对便宜，因为就像我说的，它已经出来很长时间了。非常酷。我的本期工具也是一个游戏。它是《Workers & Resources: Soviet Republic》。哦，天哪。
Sounds like paper. please. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So it's it's set in a, you know, a member of this, you're a member of the Soviet Union, probably in like the 80s or 90s, if I had to guess, early 90s, sorry, 70s or early 80s. And it's, it's kind of like a city skylines kind of thing where your job is to set up tenements, set up factories, there's a supply chain. The thing that's, it's a thing that's pretty cool. I think that this game did a good job of is you can choose how, okay, so you know, in civilization, you can choose to have a manager manage any of your cities or all of them, right? And so, at least when I play civilization in the beginning, I start micromanaging my one city
听起来像《请出示证件》（Papers, Please）。是的。是的。是的。所以它设定在一个，你知道，你是苏联的一员，可能是在 80 年代或 90 年代，如果我必须猜测的话，90 年代初，抱歉，70 年代或 80 年代初。而且，它有点像《城市：天际线》那种东西，你的工作是建立公寓，建立工厂，有一个供应链。这件事，它是一件很酷的事情。我认为这个游戏做得很好的一点是，你可以选择如何，好的，所以你知道，在《文明》中，你可以选择让经理管理你的任何城市或所有城市，对吧？所以，至少当我玩《文明》时，一开始，我开始微观管理我的一个城市
because I feel like I need to get the avalanche going faster than everybody else. So I need that tiny snowball to start, right? But then once the avalanche is going, and especially if I'm winning, I'll just turn all the cities on managed mode and then just focus on my army and just winning the game, right? And so this has that mechanic in it where you can choose the level of simulation. And so, you know, you can actually go all the way down to like each individual person needs to be fed and have all. their needs met and you even need to like bus them to their job so you need a bus route and all that but as your city grows you can kind of like
因为我觉得我需要比其他人更快地让雪崩开始。所以我需要那个小雪球开始，对吧？但一旦雪崩开始，特别是如果我赢了，我就会把所有城市都调成管理模式，然后只专注于我的军队并赢得游戏，对吧？所以这个游戏里有那个机制，你可以选择模拟的级别。所以，你知道，你实际上可以一直深入到每个人都需要被喂养并满足所有需求，你甚至需要像用公共汽车把他们送到工作岗位，所以你需要一条公交路线等等，但随着你的城市发展，你可以有点像
up the level of simulation and then it will start like automatically trying to do the right thing there and so in the end you're kind of running like a pretty large city and you're kind of managing all these different AIs and trying to make more strategic decisions so I was still pretty early in the game so I haven't uncovered a lot of it yet.
提高模拟级别，然后它就会开始像自动尝试在那里做正确的事情，所以最后你有点像在运行一个相当大的城市，你有点在管理所有这些不同的 AI 并试图做出更具战略性的决策，所以我还在游戏的早期，所以我还没有发现很多东西。
But it's very cheap. It's on sale, which the sale is probably going to be over by the time the show airs. But you can put it on your wish list. It'll go on sale again. But I found it a lot of fun, actually. And it's kind of a twist on the city building
但它非常便宜。它在打折，虽然节目播出时折扣可能已经结束了。但你可以把它放在你的愿望清单上。它会再次打折的。但我发现它实际上很有趣。而且它有点像城市建设的转折
that I haven't seen. That sounds squaw off the channel. Although my initial search for it tells me people saying it's a very hard game. And so I'm nervous. Okay, yeah, to be fair, I have been playing on very easy. Okay.
我还没见过。听起来很不错。虽然我最初对它的搜索告诉我人们说这是一个非常难的游戏。所以我很紧张。好的，是的，公平地说，我一直在玩非常简单的模式。好的。
So I'm still sort of exploring the game. We'll see if it's become so hard that the play on normal is just not forgiving. I saw something. I used to feel bad about this. And then I saw a quote keep popping up, I think on Reddit or somewhere where the person who made Eldon Ring and some of the other really difficult games, which I've not played, points out that even though they're really popular for making these very hard games, that they actually kind of suck at video games
所以我还在探索这个游戏。我们看看它是否变得太难了，以至于在普通模式下玩是不宽容的。我看到了什么。我过去常为此感到难过。然后我看到一个引语不断出现，我想是在 Reddit 或其他地方，制作《艾尔登法环》和其他一些非常困难的游戏的人，我没玩过，指出尽管他们因为制作这些非常难的游戏而非常受欢迎，但他们实际上在玩电子游戏方面有点烂
and they use everything they can to just make the game easier for them to play through. So they build these games that are super difficult, but yet they themselves play it on basically like, give me mode. And I'm like, oh, okay, I feel a lot better than even the like, I'm not alone. So I shouldn't feel bad for doing this.
他们利用他们能利用的一切来让游戏更容易玩。所以他们制作了这些超级困难的游戏，但他们自己却基本上是在“给我模式”下玩。我就说，哦，好的，我感觉好多了，甚至像，我并不孤单。所以我不需要因为这样做而感到难过。
Yeah, the only game I really play on hard are these turn-based kind of tactical games. Like I got the Final Fantasy Tactics remake on Switch. And I played that on the hardest setting. And, you know, the thing about those games is once you have the patterns down, then you just kind of know what buttons to press. So I feel like I don't know that much about Dark Souls like games. But my guess is that those people who play those games have like just a lot of muscle memory.
是的，我真正玩困难模式的唯一游戏是这些回合制的战术游戏。比如我在 Switch 上买了《最终幻想战略版》重制版。我是在最难的设置下玩的。而且，你知道，这些游戏的事情是，一旦你掌握了模式，你就知道该按什么按钮了。所以我感觉我对像《黑暗之魂》那样的游戏了解不多。但我的猜测是，那些玩这些游戏的人只是有很多肌肉记忆。
All right. Time for the topic of this show, which is either going to be a love it or hate it topic, but we're here for it, provide our own hot takes. Becoming a manager. So let's give a little background before we start. So Patrick is a manager. Do you manage managers? Yes.
好了。是时候讨论本节目的主题了，这要么是一个让人喜欢要么让人讨厌的话题，但我们在这里，提供我们自己的热点看法。成为一名经理。所以在我们开始之前，先提供一点背景。所以帕特里克是一名经理。你管理经理吗？是的。
Okay, so Patrick is a mom. I call those people moms. Patrick is a manager of managers. Obviously, Patrick has been a what I call a line manager, which means a manager of pure all individual contributors, and obviously Patrick's been individual contributors. So on my end, I have more or less done the same. So I've been in visual contributor, a manager, a mom.
好的，所以帕特里克是一位妈妈（Manager of Managers）。我称那些人为妈妈。帕特里克是一位经理的经理。显然，帕特里克曾经是我所说的直线经理，这意味着纯粹管理所有个人贡献者，显然帕特里克曾经是个人贡献者。所以在我这边，我或多或少做了同样的事情。所以我曾经是个人贡献者，经理，妈妈。
I think one time I managed a manager of managers or something like that. I don't know. There's one more level there, but it was like one part of my organization. So I barely dipped a toe into the next level. and I've been in I see sporadically throughout that. So Patrick and I have kind of done the thing, so to speak. So, yeah, we're not, we didn't do a ton of research going into this. We never do.
我想有一次我管理过经理的经理什么的。我不知道。那里还有一级，但那是我组织的一部分。所以我几乎没有涉足下一级。而且我一直零星地担任个人贡献者。所以帕特里克和我或多或少都做过这件事，可以说。所以，是的，我们没有，我们在进入这个话题之前没有做大量的研究。我们从来不做。
I feel like it's more like it's better for us to just give our own experiences rather than tell you to go read someone else's experiences. So you're going to get kind of, as Patrick said, our hot takes, but, you know, there are takes of people who have kind of been there and done that. And I think to Jason's point, it'll come from the point of view of people who have been specifically engineers in our cases because that's what we know. And then being asked to or having the opportunity or wanting to become a manager, I think there are other people who come up in sort of a more direct path to a manager or from product management roles or other things. And we're not, I don't think we're going to have much to say except by incidental. sort of discussion about those things. And similarly, we're not going to talk about like what it
我觉得最好还是让我们给出自己的经验，而不是告诉你们去读别人的经验。所以你们会得到，正如帕特里克所说，我们的热点看法，但是，你知道，这是那些曾经身临其境的人的看法。而且我认为对于杰森的观点，它将来自我们这些特定工程师的观点，因为这是我们所知道的。然后被要求或有机会或想要成为一名经理，我认为还有其他人以更直接的路径成为经理，或者来自产品管理角色或其他事情。而且我们不是，我不认为我们除了偶然的讨论之外，对这些事情没什么可说的。同样，我们不会谈论如果你自己不是工程师，管理一名工程师意味着什么。是的，很好的呼吁。是的，正如你所说，也有盲点，但是，你知道，了解我们的受众，我觉得我们可能有很多听众，他们要么正在考虑成为一名经理，要么他们走的是同样的轨迹，希望这能帮助你们。那么什么是经理，帕特里克？嗯，我本来要开始的。我不知道。我不会尝试做执行摘要。
means to manage an engineer if you've not been an engineer yourself. Yeah, good call out. Yeah, there's also, as you said, there's blind spots, but, you know, knowing our audience, I feel like we probably have a lot of people out there who are either thinking about becoming a manager or they've kind of followed sort of the same trajectory and hopefully this will help you a folks out. So what is a manager, Patrick? Well, I was going to start. I don't know. I'm not going to attempt to do the executive summary.
我讨厌执行摘要。我问 ChatGPT，什么是经理？但经理是帮助组织他人任务的人。而且我认为对于这次讨论，在很大程度上，我们将专注于管理个人贡献者。所以那些他们自己正在做技术工作的人，虽然你作为经理可能自己也在做技术工作，无论是贡献，进行同行评审，
I hate executive summaries. I asked chat, JBT, what is a manager? But a manager is someone who helps to organize the tasks of other individuals. And I think for this discussion, for the most part, we'll focus on managing individual contributors. So people who are they themselves doing technical work, while you may be doing, technical work yourself as a manager as well, either contributing, doing peer reviews,
执行，比如代码检查，你知道，帮助引导方向，架构等等。而且我认为有几个，我猜，比如高层观察，
perform, sort of like code checks, you know, helping to sort of steer direction, architecture and that kind of stuff. And I think a couple of, I guess, like high level observations,
在我们进入之前，第一件事就是机会。所以除非你有点像创办一家企业并进行创业，在大多数情况下，如果你在某个地方进行个人贡献，很可能会有一个时间，
um, before we get in is, the first thing is like opportunity. So unless you are kind of like starting a business and doing a startup, for the most part, if you're individual contributing somewhere, there is likely going to be a time,
至少根据我的经验，如果你作为个人贡献者做得很好，会有人过来问你是否愿意管理另一个人，或者如果经理要离开，他们可能会要求你接管一个团队。我想也许我们会谈到它，但开始你自己的团队与接管一个团队之间存在差异，这是非常明显的。但如果你已经做了很长时间的个人贡献者，你需要考虑这是否是你想要做的事情。而且在大多数好的公司里，他们会尝试为那些不想成为经理的人提供路径，他们应该尝试在他们之间保持薪酬水平相当。所以这不应该仅仅是一个财务决定，在你的当前工作和薪水变化中成为经理而不是留在个人贡献者，尽管结果可能会有所不同。这可能在很大程度上取决于你在哪里。
at least to my experience, if you're doing well as an individual contributor, where someone will come along and ask you if you would like to manage another person or if a manager is leaving, they may ask you to take over a team. I think maybe we'll get to it, but there are differences between sort of starting your own team
但那个机会会到来，而且它可能不止一次到来。它可能只来一次。它可能来很多次。如果当你过渡到一家新公司时，它可能是被谈论的事情，但绝对是你进入那种情况之前想要考虑的事情
versus taking over a team that are pretty distinct. But it is something that if you've been an individual contributor for a while, you need to kind of think about whether it's something you want to do. And in most good companies, they try to provide paths for people who don't want to become managers and who do and should try to generally keep the pay scale equivalent between them. So that is it shouldn't be strictly a financial decision at your current job and salary change to become a manager versus stay an individual contributor, although results may vary. that can highly depend on where you are.
而不是任何特定的时间，对吧？你永远不知道，但要考虑一下这是否是你想要承担的事情。是的，这是一个很好的呼吁。我会说经理和工程师之间的巨大区别是，作为一名工程师，你被期望达到某种关键结果。所以你说，我们要在本季度让 Instagram 上的点击量增加 1%。
But that opportunity will come, and it may come more than once. It may only come once. It may come lots. It may be something that's talked about if you transition to a new company, but definitely something you want to think about before you get into that situation
然后你编码，编码，你运行测试，你构建模型。你用新模型替换旧模型，然后砰，你得到了 1.5%，你超出了你的预期，对吧？作为一名经理，你还必须增加留存率，而衡量结果的方式非常不同。但分类上的区别在于你必须增加留存率。
and sort of not any specific time, right? You never know, but kind of thinking through if that's something you want to take on or not. Yeah, that's a good call out. I would say that the big difference between a manager and an engineer is as an engineer, you're expected to meet some sort of key results. So you say, we're going to get clicks on Instagram to go up by 1% this quarter.
关于留存率的事情是，它是一个非常滞后的指标，对吧？所以如果你的团队有一半人辞职，嗯，就像你或你的经理真的搞砸了，因为他们应该更早地看到留存率问题。但是，你知道，稍微愤世嫉俗一点，你知道，如果人们愿意不拿工资留下来，假设人们只是如此热情，他们愿意留下来拿零美元。嗯，这就是公司应该付给他们的，对吧？我的意思是，我知道我们在这里有点愤世嫉俗，但是，但是，你知道，留存率是公司，特别是关键人才和高潜力人才的留存率。这就是公司衡量其领导力健康状况的方式。所以，所以你必须在继续交付良好结果的同时，为自己增加那个维度。是的，实际上，你提出了一个很好的观点。我会通过说我认为我们正在谈论经理既考虑任务也考虑人来搞乱你的结果和留存率的头韵。而且有严格的人员经理，他们不负责技术任务和关键绩效指标，只负责个人成长、幸福感、留存率。还有你想要称之为技术经理的任何东西，他们是，你知道，管理项目和技术团队和任务，而不直接负责个人的成长或留存，正如你所说的那样。而且，我个人哲学中的一些东西，但我尝试向我团队中的人传达，即对两者负责，你知道，我对任务和人都负责。而且我尝试告诉他们，随着他们的成长，不是可选的，而是必须具备的，是领导力。领导力不是可选的，无论他们是否在技术工作之外成为人员经理，他们都需要领导技术工作。这就是推动良好的架构，管理代码库，帮助组织其他人
And you code, code, and you run tests, and you build models. and you replace old models with new models, and then boom, you get one and a half percent and you exceeded your expectations, right? As a manager, you also have to add retention to it, and the way the results are measured is pretty different. But the sort of categorical difference is that you have to add retention.
在关键想法背后，并以某种方式团结人们支持他们的事业，并成为一个获胜的个性，就像你想要称之为软技能的任何东西，但这些事情并不是真正可以协商的，如果你不愿意领导并帮助展示一种其他人可以跟随你的方式，无论你是否在人员上管理他们，那么上升和获得晋升等等将会非常困难。这是我个人的方法。可能有其他方法，但在我做的方式中，我认为作为个人贡献者这样想是一个好方法。你在做你自己的事情，但你也在以一种其他人可以跟随、模仿你的方式做，
And the thing about retention is it's like a massively laggy indicator, right? So if half your team quits, well, like you've, like you or your manager have like really messed up because they should have seen the retention problem like way further in advance. But, you know, to be a little cynical, you know, if people are willing to stay for no pay, let's say people are just so passionate, they're willing to stay for zero dollars. Well, that's what the company should pay them, right? I mean, I know we're being kind of cynical here, but, but, you know, retention is the way that companies, especially retention of key talent and high rising folks. That's the way that companies kind of measure the health of their leadership. So, so you have to add that dimension to yourself to be a manager while continuing to deliver good results. Yeah, actually, you bring up a great point. I'll mess up your alliteration of results and retention by saying, I think we're talking about managers as thinking about both tasks and people. And there are strictly people managers, which are not responsible for technical sort of tasking and key performance indicators, but just of sort of personal growth, happiness, retention. And there are also whatever you want to call like technical.
你正在设定良好的模式，建立实践，通过这种方式你正在领导，无论你所领导的人是否在组织结构中处于你的下属。是的，我的意思是，我会说的一件事是，我们以前在公司工作过，是的，有纯粹的人员经理。
managers who are, you know, managing projects and sort of like technical teams and tasks without being responsible for the growth of individuals directly or retention, as you're kind of saying. And I, something that maybe is a personal philosophy, but I try to communicate to people on my team as being responsible for both, you know, I'm responsible for both tasks and people. And I try to tell them that as they're growing, that one of the things that's not, is a must have, not an optional, is leading. That leadership is something that's not optional, that whether they become a people manager in addition to their technical work, they need to be leading technical work regardless. That is driving good architecture, managing the code base, helping organize other people
他们被称为职能经理，我想。但总的来说，大多数公司，大多数经理将负责两者。现在，这并不意味着该经理将交付任何这些结果，但他们最终负责这些结果，这使他们能够决定规模。所以基于他们负责的关键结果有多少，他们可以将其作为决定是否雇佣更多人的指标之一
behind key ideas and sort of rallying folks towards their cause and being a winning personality, like whatever you want to kind of say as sort of soft skills, but that those things are not really negotiable, that if you aren't willing to sort of lead and help demonstrate a way that other people can come behind you, whether you manage them as people or not, then it is going to be very difficult to rise and to get promotions and that kind of stuff. That's my personal approach to it. There may be other ways, but in the way that I do it, and I think it's a good way as an individual contributor to think about it. You're doing your own thing, but then you are also doing it in a way in which other people could follow, mimic you,
或者在另一端，如果他们能负责的结果不多。这里有一个例子。假设你在安全团队，代码库的变化不多，所以你的安全团队没有太多东西要审查。嗯，这给你可以雇佣多少人设定了一个硬性限制。所以人员管理和技术之间存在这种联系。它们确实在那个领域有重叠。
you're setting good patterns, establishing practices, and in that way you're leading, whether or not the people whom you are leading, like, are under you in the organizational structure. Yeah, I mean, one thing that I would say is, we've worked at companies before where, yeah, there were pure people managers.
但是，但是是的，管理的一个重要部分是调整规模和扩大或缩小团队。所以你扩大团队的方式是通过招聘。所以作为一名经理，你将变得非常擅长查看简历，快速了解，你知道，快速评估某人的，你知道，既有他们当前的能力，也有他们的能力，他们未来的能力，你知道，在面试中快速评估。最终，像，决定，你知道，是否进行招聘。
They're called like functional managers, I think. But generally speaking, most companies, most managers will be responsible for both. Now, it doesn't mean that that manager will be delivering any of those results, but they are sort of at the end of day responsible for those results, and that allows them to decide sizing. So based on sort of how much of the sort of key results they're responsible for, they can use that as one of the indicators to decide whether to hire more people
通常有一个招聘委员会，所以你不是自己做那个决定。但你将在那个委员会中拥有很大的发言权，因为你直接对那个人负责。是的，我的意思是，我认为这是一个，我们在播客之前谈论了很多关于面试的事情。但现在我们从不同的角度谈论它。我认为这是未被谈论但关键的事情之一，我在新经理甚至经验丰富的经理身上看到了它，那就是在现实中，很多时候关于雇佣谁的决定，比如特定的人，是你的决定。
or on the other end, if there just isn't that many results that they could be responsible for. So here's an example of that. Let's say you're on the security team, and there just isn't that much, that many changes to the code base, and so there just isn't that much for your security team to review. Well, that kind of puts a hard limit on how many folks you can hire. So there's kind of like this connection between, you know, between sort of the people management and the technical. They do kind of overlap in that area.
而且你作为经理有责任做出那个最终决定。现在，可能有事情阻止了它，对吧？你无法获得你想要的薪酬方案。那个人不接受，等等。但归根结底，如果那个人加入你的团队，他们很糟糕，他们影响了他们自己和团队的其他成员。就像，那是你的责任。让他们跟上进度，那是你的责任。
But, but yeah, a big part of management is sizing and growing and shrinking the team. And so the way you grow the team is through hiring. So as a manager, you will become very adept at looking at resumes, quickly getting to, you know, quickly assessing someone's, you know, both their current competence and their ability, their future competence, you know, quickly in an interview. And ultimately, like, kind of deciding, you know, whether to kind of go-no-go hiring folks.
就像，你知道，这是你必须非常深思熟虑的事情之一，关于挑选合适的人。老实说，我做了很多很多面试，看到很多人被雇佣或没被雇佣。我从未见过我所说的完美候选人，一个候选人就像，绝对没有任何我们担心的事情。这是绝对我们应该全力以赴。并尽一切可能雇佣这个人。如果有的话，我可能会非常害怕
There's usually a hiring committee, so you're not making that decision by yourself. But you're going to be a very big voice in that committee because you're directly responsible for that person. Yeah, I mean, I think that's a, we talked a lot about interviews on our podcast before. But now we're talking about it a little bit from a different side. I think it is one of the not talked about but key things. and I see it in new managers or even experienced managers, which is in reality, many times the call on who to hire, like a specific person, is your call.
因为那可能非常昂贵。而那本身就是一种挣扎。但是，你知道，几乎总是有一些缺点。那些候选人，你会想，他们会跳槽吗？他们为什么要这份工作？他们会要求晋升吗？所以，是的，从来没有完美的候选人。
And you're responsible as manager for making that final decision. Now, there could be things that prevented, right? You're not able to get the compensation package you want. The person doesn't accept, whatever. But at the end of the day, if that person joins your team and they're bad and they impact themselves and the rest of the team. Like, that's on you. Getting them up to speed, that's on you.
是的，是的。所以归根结底，只是对那种风险感到舒适并自己承担它，这在我看来，与个人贡献者不同，作为经理你最终不得不承担风险的事情数量。这是你的风险。如果你做错了，你的经理会责怪你。你下面的人如果你做错了会责怪你。而且真的没有其他人可以转向和指责。是的，这是一个很棒的隐喻。我只想拉动那根线。所以，你知道，
Like, you know, and it's one of those things that you have to be very thoughtful about, about picking the right person. And to be honest, like, I've done many, many interviews, seen many people hired or not hired. I've never seen what I would call it is a perfect candidate, a candidate that was just like, there is absolutely no thing that we're concerned about. This is absolutely we should go all out. and do everything possible to hire this person. If there was, I'd probably be really scared
我会把它与金钱和苏联以及马克思等等联系起来。所以，所以如果你考虑一个工人工作，你知道，假设一个小时工，你知道，工作那个小时并得到那个工资。但实际上所有者应该得到任何东西的原因是什么？假设所有者实际上并不管理便利店或其他任何东西。嗯，这是因为所有者承担了风险。所有者投入了大量资本到那个便利店，他们本可以投入到股市或其他什么地方。只是把它放在宝箱里或其他什么地方。但相反，他们把它投入到了这个便利店。他们在第一天就损失了所有。然后他们把它建立起来，现在他们得到了
because it'd probably be very expensive. And then itself would be a sort of struggle. But, you know, almost always are some downside. Those candidates then, you're like, are they a flight risk? Why are they taking this job? Are they going to demand a promotion? So, yeah, there's never a perfect candidate.
股息。所以，所以所有者正在从这个巨大的风险中获得股息，而工人正在因为他们的劳动而得到报酬。所以作为一名经理，你知道，即使你不拥有公司，我认为那种隐喻也成立，其中，你知道，我承担了负担。我作为经理所做的所有糟糕决定的负担。正如帕特里克所说，许多这些决定需要多年时间才能和解。也许它们永远不会被和解，对吧？所以你只需要忍受它。这是相当独特的事情。
Yep, yep. And so that always comes down to at the end of the day, just being comfortable with that risk and eating it yourself, which is, in my opinion, different than individual contributor, the number of things as a manager you end up having to what I call eat the risk for. It's your risk. Your manager's going to blame you if you get it wrong. The people under you are going to blame you if you get it wrong. And there's really no one else to turn and point to. Yeah, that's an amazing metaphor. I want to just pull on that thread. So, you know,
我的意思是，作为一名工程师，当你选择编程语言或架构或其他什么时，你可能会有这种情况。但总的来说，你不会像经理那样背负同样的阴云。这只是你学习的东西。在其中茁壮成长。所以谈到如何管理，有哪些部分归结为作为经理完成工作的日常、月度方面？是的，我来介绍第一个。
I'll connect it to money and sort of like the Soviet Union and Marx and all that. So, So if you think about a worker kind of works, you know, let's say an hourly worker, you know, works that hour and gets that salary. But what actually is the reason why the owner should get anything? Let's say the owner doesn't actually manage the convenience store or whatever it is. Well, it's because the owner took a risk. The owner put in a bunch of capital into that convenience store that they could have put into the stock market or whatever. just held it in a treasure chest or something. But instead they put it into this convenience store. They lost all of it, you know, on day one. And then they built it back up and now they're getting
你作为经理的工作，这是真的，无论你是中层经理、高管等等。如果你是高管，上面可能没有人。董事有点完全不同的事情。股东。但是的，你有点像一个委员会。所以你仍然必须倡导。仍然有
dividends. So, so the owner is getting dividends on this big risk while the worker is getting kind of paid for their labor. And so as a manager, you know, even if you don't own the company, I think that same kind of metaphor holds where, where, you know, I carry the burden. of all the bad decisions that I've made as a manager. And as Patrick said, a lot of these decisions take years and years to reconcile. And maybe they never get reconciled, right? And so you just have to live with that. That is something that is pretty unique.
某种，你知道，如果你想要什么，而其他高管都不想要，那么你就得不到它。所以他们集体是你在那个论点上的上级。对。所以过程或多或少
I mean, as an engineer, you might have this when it comes to picking a programming language or an architecture or something. But by and large, you don't carry that same kind of cloud over you as you do a manager. That's just something that you learn. to thrive in. So talking about how to manage, what are some of the pieces that come down to kind of the day-to-day, the month-to-month aspects of accomplishing the job as a manager? Yeah, I'll cover the first one.
在链条上一直是一样的，公司有一个目标。假设目标是，你知道，公司制造，它是一个橙子合作社。公司种植橙子，在橙子林里。
Your job as a manager, and this is true, whether you're a middle manager, an executive, et cetera. If you're an executive, there might not be anybody above you per se. directors kind of totally different things. Stockholders. But yeah, you're kind of a council. And so you still have to advocate. There's still
作为经理，你的工作是这样的，无论你是中层经理、高管等等，这都是事实。如果你是高管，可能就没有人直接管你了。董事的情况则完全不同。股东也是。但确实，你就像是在一个委员会里。所以你仍然需要去倡导。仍然有
sort of like a you know, if you want something and none of the other executives want it, well then you're not going to get it. And so they kind of collectively are your superior for that one argument. Right. So the process is more or less
某种程度上，你知道，如果你想要什么，而其他高管都不想要，那你也就得不到。所以对于那个特定的议题，他们集体就是你的上级。对吧。所以这个过程或多或少是
the same all the way up the chain where the company has a goal. Let's say the goal is, you know, the company makes, it's an orange cooperative. The company grows oranges, in orange grows.
在整个链条上都是一样的，公司有一个目标。比方说目标是，你知道，公司生产，它是一个橙子合作社。公司种植橙子，在橙子种植园里。
And what your job as a manager is, or management, let's say, collectively, is to break that goal down. So I guess tech is a better example. Maybe the goal of the company is to, to run this sort of ad service and this run like a Google search engine and the ad service. That's the company. But somehow that goal has to be broken down into such a fine grain that you can justify like upgrading Python.
作为经理，或者说作为管理层，你的工作就是将目标进行拆解。我们以科技行业为例，也许公司的目标是运营某种广告服务，或者像谷歌那样运营搜索引擎和广告服务。这就是公司。但这个目标必须被拆解得足够细致，细致到你可以证明升级 Python 是合理的。
Like why should the company move to Python 3.14? So someone's got to draw like a causal link from the overall goal of the company. And some of those goals are sort of like, I guess, spiritual in a sense. Like, you know, maybe like Google's motto, you organize the world's information. It's kind of like more of like a spiritual or inspirational goal. But you could kind of, you have to draw a line from that all the way down to, okay, we're going to abolish Python 3.7, right? Or something like that.
比如，公司为什么要升级到 Python 3.14？所以必须有人能从公司的整体目标中建立起因果联系。其中一些目标在某种意义上是“精神层面”的。比如谷歌的座右铭“整合全球信息”，这更像是一个精神或激励性的目标。但你必须从这个目标出发，一路推导到具体的行动，比如“我们要废弃 Python 3.7”，诸如此类。
So your job as a manager is to do that and also size the opportunity and the risk. So if you say, sure, me and my team of two people are going to upgrade all of Google to Python 3.11, well, like, you just took on a goal that is just not going to happen. And so you're going to fail at that goal. People are going to get burnt out. And it's just going to be very frustrating, right? Or you're going to have to hire a ton of people very quickly. on the flip side, if you say, if you make a goal but you don't kind of draw that line and correctly,
所以，作为经理，你的工作就是完成这种拆解，并评估机会与风险。如果你说：“没问题，我和我的两人团队要把整个谷歌升级到 Python 3.11”，那你承担了一个根本不可能实现的目标。结果就是你会失败，团队成员会精疲力竭，这会让人非常沮丧。或者你必须非常迅速地雇佣大量人员。反过来说，如果你设定了目标，但没有正确地建立起这种联系，
or it's just not ambitious enough, then even when people accomplish the goal, you know, they won't be able to get recognized for that accomplishment because it's just not tied back to the company in a way that's influential. So that's, I think, the biggest part of being a manager is getting that part right. And I think a lot of that comes down to trying to set up frameworks so that the people under you can make those decisions. Like, the higher you are up, you don't want to be, you know, minor versions of Python to be something brought to you. You want to establish the framing so that the people under you understand the key concepts of maintainability. of, you know, getting new features, of hiring, of those kinds of things, and are able to make those decisions and give you the high level,
或者目标不够宏大，那么即使人们完成了目标，他们也无法因此获得认可，因为它与公司有影响力的目标没有关联。我认为，这是做经理最重要的一部分。而且我认为，很大程度上这取决于如何建立框架，让下属能够做出这些决策。职位越高，你越不希望事无巨细地处理 Python 的小版本更新。你需要建立框架，让下属理解可维护性、获取新功能、招聘等关键概念，并让他们能够做出决策，而你只负责处理框架无法覆盖的高层级、
sort of like hard or arbitrary things that the framework doesn't cover. Yeah, yeah, yeah, that makes sense. So another thing about managing is thinking about, you know, a role as sort of a coach, that you have the players on your team, you have these goals that you're working towards, the game field and rules have been set, and now you need to get everybody to kind of play together and develop the individual players.
或者说比较棘手、随意的事务。没错，这很有道理。关于管理的另一件事是，要把角色看作教练。团队里有球员，有你们共同努力的目标，比赛场地和规则已经设定好了，现在你需要让每个人协同作战，并培养每一位球员。
And I guess to kind of make up the word there, you know, thinking about yourself as a coach. And so now you start to think about things like having one-on-one meetings with the people on the team. And some people hate one-on-one, some people love one-on-one, sometimes they happen weekly,
我想造个词的话，就是把自己看作教练。于是你开始考虑一些事情，比如与团队成员进行一对一谈话。有些人讨厌一对一，有些人喜欢，有时每周进行一次，
sometimes they happen never. The race can kind of vary where you, individually work through all of the people on your team and sort of talk about the various things about how they're doing, about what they want, making sure that you think about their retention, about their growth, about their happiness, whether they're burning out. You know, if there's other tasks, you should be sort of giving them opportunities for growth. And, you know, sometimes in many companies I've been at, the concept of career planning is something that happens like right around performance review time. But it really should be a constant discussion.
有时从不进行。节奏可以有所不同，你可以逐一与团队成员沟通，谈论他们的工作表现、他们的诉求，确保你关注他们的留存、成长、幸福感，以及他们是否处于倦怠期。如果还有其他任务，你应该为他们提供成长的机会。在很多我待过的公司里，职业规划的概念通常只在绩效评估期间出现。但实际上，这应该是一个持续的讨论。
Hey, you did really great at this. Hey, this is an area where I expected you to try to do a little more. Or hey, have you considered also helping out on this thing, right? It's a sort of ongoing continual thing to help that. And it seems like an overly formal word, but just having the conversation with people where you're trying to help them be better. Yeah. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, I think, I think, you know, one-on-ones of kind of my strategy is changed over time, but the current strategy I have is basically, you know, I want them to be like relatively frequent, so weekly or bi-weekly, but pretty short. So you should be able to say, here's a piece of good feedback, here's something that was lacking. You know, why don't you?
“嘿，你在这方面做得很好。嘿，这是我希望你多努力一点的地方。或者，嘿，你有没有考虑过协助处理这件事？”这是一种持续不断的帮助。虽然“正式”这个词听起来有点生硬，但与人们进行对话，试图帮助他们变得更好，就是这么回事。没错，这很有道理。我认为，我的一对一策略随着时间有所改变，但目前的策略基本上是：我希望频率相对高一些，比如每周或每两周一次，但时间要短。你应该能够说出：“这是一条好的反馈，这是不足之处。”
tell me what's on your mind and hopefully you can get that done in 30 minutes or even a little less than that. But you want it often enough that people don't forget something and then you only get half the story. Oh, that's a good point. Yeah. Yeah, I think another big part of managing is the performance review system. And so this is this is something that I, I think a lot of engineers don't understand. The performance review system is ultimately an incentive system. It's a system that's there to drive incentives. And so because it's designed to drive incentives,
“告诉我你在想什么”，希望能在 30 分钟甚至更短的时间内完成。但你需要保持足够的频率，以免人们忘记某些事情，导致你只能听到片面的情况。哦，这很有道理。是的，我认为管理的另一个重要部分是绩效评估系统。这是很多工程师不理解的地方。绩效评估系统本质上是一个激励系统。它是为了驱动激励而存在的。正因为它旨在驱动激励，
by nature it has to change because the incentives of the company change over time. So for example, this is way before I joined, but Facebook had a reputation for like poor, what's the word? Like poor uptime, particularly like Messenger. I don't know if you remember this. I mean, I remember this as a user. Messenger, I'd go to send a message and sometimes it would just fail. It's like, how can I am fail, you know?
它必然会发生变化，因为公司的激励机制会随时间而改变。举个例子，这发生在我加入之前，Facebook 曾因“糟糕的正常运行时间”而闻名，特别是 Messenger。不知道你是否记得。作为用户我记得，Messenger 发送消息时有时会失败。心想：怎么连即时通讯都会失败？
So, but, you know, it was a reliability crisis. I don't know, maybe 2007, 2008-ish. and at some point it leaked that Facebook had one site reliability engineer for every two engineers, software engineers. So it's like the system was just constantly falling apart. And so they made a push to, again, all is before I joined, but they made a push to like do stable infrastructure. and they bought the company that made H-base, they bought Bunchy's open-source projects or built them from the ground up,
所以，那是一场可靠性危机，大概在 2007 或 2008 年左右。后来有消息泄露说，Facebook 每两名软件工程师才配备一名站点可靠性工程师（SRE）。系统当时一直在崩溃。于是他们推动了变革——再次强调，这是在我加入之前——他们推动了稳定基础设施的建设，收购了开发 HBase 的公司，收购或从零构建了许多开源项目，
but they hired like a ton of people who were really good at solid infrastructure. And they added to the performance management system a new axis called engineering excellence, where people would talk about how, you know, they built something that, you know, was defendable, that, that, uh, reliable. robust, et cetera, et cetera.
他们雇佣了大量擅长稳固基础设施的人才。并在绩效管理系统中增加了一个名为“工程卓越”的新维度，人们会讨论他们如何构建了可防御、可靠、健壮等特性的系统。
And so, you know, that, that, that access was added to push the company in a certain direction, right? And so people, especially junior folks, will look at the performance management system as if it like was handed on stone tablets, you know? And then, and especially if things change or if it's interpreted differently, you know, one year versus a next, they're super discouraged, right? And so as a manager, your job is to both like see the trends that are coming up,
所以，增加这个维度是为了推动公司向特定方向发展。因此，人们，尤其是初级员工，会把绩效管理系统看作是刻在石碑上的金科玉律。如果情况发生变化，或者每年的解读方式不同，他们会感到非常沮丧。所以作为经理，你的工作是既要看到即将到来的趋势，
you know, be a part of the change so that you can look around corners and just communicate well, you know, to your team, you know, of where the company, like where the puck is going. Yeah, I think that as individual contributors, you look for like what is the checklist of things I need to do to get the highest raise.
又要参与变革，这样你才能预见未来，并向团队传达公司发展的方向。是的，我认为作为个人贡献者（IC），你会寻找“我需要完成哪些清单才能获得最高加薪”。
And I think to your point, Jason, it's just like not how it works. And it's sort of a mis-expectation if you think that's how it works. And I've seen bad, I've seen less bad, but I don't think anyone sort of goes around saying they have like solved how to do performance management. Right, exactly. It's kind of like no one can perfectly balance on. a tight rope. So where like half of the atoms in their body are on one end of the tight rope and it never moves, right? So, so, you know, it's constant adaptation. Yeah. And I mean, I think it sets up, and I'm not trying to be like a negative person about it, but there's a natural tension where
正如你所说，Jason，事情并不是这样运作的。如果你认为这就是工作方式，那是一种错误的预期。我见过糟糕的，也见过没那么糟的，但我认为没有人敢说他们已经彻底解决了绩效管理的问题。没错，就像没有人能完美地走钢丝一样。你不可能让身体里一半的原子永远固定在钢丝的一端，它从不移动。所以，这需要不断的适应。是的，而且我认为这造成了一种自然的张力，我并不是想表现得消极，但
the company wants to retain people for the least amount of, you know, pay increase and least amount of salary because it's a cost and still get what they want out of it. But they know that they can't not do it. And so they must do it, but they want to do the least of it. And from an individual standpoint, you want to maximize how much you're being paid. So it sets up this natural, and there's all sorts of philosophies on how to measure if your system is working or not working, retention numbers, you know, improvement numbers. And there's flaws with all of it. But ultimately, it's just not, it's a sort of unstable thing. It's a, it ebbs and flows as the company is doing well, as the stock market is doing well, as your division in the company is doing well. You know,
公司希望以最低的加薪和薪水留住员工，因为这是成本，同时还要获得他们想要的结果。但他们知道不能不这样做。所以他们必须做，但想做得最少。而从个人角度来看，你希望最大化你的薪酬。这造成了一种自然的张力。关于如何衡量系统是否有效，有各种各样的哲学，比如留存率、改进率。所有这些都有缺陷。但归根结底，它是不稳定的。随着公司表现、股市表现、部门表现的好坏，它会起伏不定。
all of those things change. You know, investor sentiment, what they're looking for. Are they looking for cost cutting or are they looking for growth? Like all of those things impact what ultimately feels like a very personal thing. Yep. Yep, totally agree. I mean, the one sort of solace here is, you know, Patrick and I are both, what, mid-40s, right? Early to mid-40s. And, I mean, I feel like there's still a ton of career left, but I also feel like I'm kind of done sort of chasing promotions. And so...
所有这些因素都会改变。投资者的情绪，他们看重什么？是削减成本还是追求增长？所有这些都会影响到最终看起来非常私人的事情。没错，完全同意。我想，这里唯一的慰藉是，Patrick 和我都是四十岁左右，对吧？四十岁出头。我觉得职业生涯还有很长，但也觉得我有点不想再追逐晋升了。所以……
No, no, no, you're not allowed to say that. Don't negotiate against yourself. Well, I mean, my point is to junior folks out there, if you didn't, you know, make... senior this time around, it's not that big a deal, right? And so, you know, it's no reflection on you. It could just be the company, you know, really cared about stability and you're working on, like, the new version of TikTok or whatever, and the companies didn't care about it that much this time around. It's very possible, very, very possible. It could be like everything was perfect
不，不，不，你不能这么说。不要跟自己谈判。我的意思是，对于初级员工，如果你这次没有升到高级职位，那没什么大不了的。这并不反映你的能力。可能只是公司这次非常看重稳定性，而你正在做 TikTok 的新版本之类的东西，公司这次不太关心那个。这很有可能。可能一切都很完美，
except your boss didn't like say sort of the right things or didn't have enough influence or, you know. And if you look like around, it could be someone else had the opposite where your boss said all the right things and they got the promotion and how did they get at their half as good as you or whatever it is. You know, I see this so much.
除了你的老板没有说出正确的话，或者没有足够的影响力。如果你环顾四周，可能会发现别人正好相反，他们的老板说了所有正确的话，他们就得到了晋升。他们怎么就比你强两倍了？我经常看到这种情况。
And like the thing to take away is like you have so many years in your career. And if you just work hard all of those years, you will eventually get what you want. I mean, at least statistically. Not every single person to a person, but statistically it will average out. Yeah, there is a tension there between, like you're saying, short term and long term. And I do think, I do see that often where especially when you're junior. And I understand it's very difficult to say, hey, just have some patience. But I will say, like you said, as a manager in general over long time horizons, things tend to work out and it tends to be okay. What that does leave out, though, is opportunities, and we talked about this thing last time for
要记住的是，你的职业生涯还有很多年。如果你在这些年里一直努力工作，最终你会得到你想要的。至少从统计学上讲是这样。不是每个人都能做到，但从统计学上讲，平均下来是会实现的。是的，短期和长期之间确实存在张力。我确实经常看到这种情况，尤其是当你还是初级员工时。我知道要说“嘿，耐心点”很难。但我会说，正如你所说，作为经理，从长远来看，事情往往会解决，一切都会好起来的。不过，这忽略了机会，我们上次谈到了
asymmetric opportunities. So, you know, leaving to a different company or a different set of opportunities. Like, those things do need to be considered and are options and not really part of this conversation. As a manager, you're trying to like, you honestly want the best for people. and sometimes that is for them to leave, but in your role as a company representative, that's not something you want to be like encouraging people to do. That's a good point. Although I think, you know,
非对称机会。所以，跳槽到不同的公司或寻找不同的机会，这些确实需要考虑，是可选项，但不属于这次谈话的内容。作为经理，你真心希望人们好，有时这意味着他们离开。但作为公司代表，你不想鼓励人们这样做。这是一个好观点。虽然我认为，
this is maybe less of a manager I see thing, individual contributor thing and more of just a senior, junior thing. But as you move further in your career and build influence, you now kind of have to live a dual life. Like if Jeff Dean went on Twitter, So Jeff Dean for folks don't know is, I think he's an individual contributor now, but he's been like managing all of Google AI
这可能不仅仅是经理与个人贡献者的区别，更多是资深与初级的区别。但随着你在职业生涯中不断前进并建立影响力，你现在必须过一种“双重生活”。比如，如果 Jeff Dean 在 Twitter 上发帖——对于不知道的人，Jeff Dean 现在应该是个人贡献者，但他曾在不同时期管理过整个谷歌 AI——
at different points in time and whatever. So someone with like a ton of influence. If he gets on Twitter, it says, you know, honestly, uh, uh, and I'm just making this up. I'm just going to pick a random team.
一个非常有影响力的人。如果他在 Twitter 上说：“老实说，我只是随便举个例子，选一个随机团队。”
You know, Waymo is just such a trash team. Like, yeah, all the other teams at Google are just so much better. No one really should go to Waymo from Google and we shouldn't take any of their people. If he posted it on Twitter, it would be devastating, right? So, first of all, that's not true.
“Waymo 真是个垃圾团队。谷歌的其他团队都好得多。没人应该从谷歌去 Waymo，我们也不应该招他们的人。”如果他发在 Twitter 上，那将是毁灭性的。首先，那不是真的。
Don't know. That's just a thought experiment hypothetical. But my point is, like, so Jeff Dean has to kind of live two lives. Like, he has to live his personal life, and maybe he's got an inner circle of people. And in that circle, he can say, look, people from Waymo are transferring to Google AI and then failing out. You know, like, we have to, you know, put the kibosh on this, right? like we have to figure out what to do. But then externally, he has to say something different.
我不知道，那只是一个思想实验。但我的意思是，Jeff Dean 必须过两种生活。他有个人生活，也许有一个核心圈子。在那个圈子里，他可以说：“看，从 Waymo 转到谷歌 AI 的人表现都不行，我们必须阻止这种情况。”但在外部，他必须说不同的话。
And to his reports, he has to say something different. And so I think that just, I don't know if this really goes into whether you should be a manager or not, but just as you mature as an employee, you start to realize that you do have these two masks that you have to wear. And that's just part of having influence and responsibility. I think, yeah, the extension of what you're saying is definitely part of choosing to become a manager is you are taking on more of an explicit company representation role. You're the one who has to deliver the bad news. You'll find out the executives love to deliver good news and they love for the managers to roll out bad news. And so lots of the bad news comes in team meetings and is your responsibility to give out.
对他的下属，他也必须说不同的话。所以我认为，这不一定关乎你是否应该成为经理，但随着你作为员工的成熟，你会意识到你必须戴上这两副面具。这是拥有影响力和责任的一部分。我认为，你所说的延伸部分，绝对是选择成为经理的一部分，那就是你承担了更明确的公司代表角色。你是那个必须传达坏消息的人。你会发现高管们喜欢传达好消息，他们喜欢让经理来发布坏消息。所以很多坏消息是在团队会议上发布的，这是你的责任。
And good news comes from other places, right? So that's just an inevitability. But there are, you know, we've set some negative. I mean, there are really good opportunities for managing as well. If you love interpersonal communications, if you like helping shape the team culture, I feel it's not the sole responsibility, but a manager is a huge portion of setting team culture. And personally, I take great joy in helping people and watching them sort of grow into better engineers and pointing back, like we were talking about AI, you know, hey, five years ago.
而好消息来自其他地方。这是一种必然。但我们谈论了一些负面因素，管理也有非常好的机会。如果你热爱人际沟通，如果你喜欢塑造团队文化，我觉得这不仅仅是经理的责任，但经理在塑造团队文化方面占很大比重。我个人从帮助他人、看着他们成长为更好的工程师中获得了巨大的快乐。就像我们谈论 AI 时提到的，五年前，
Remember when it was like this was a struggle or that and now we're doing X, Y, and Z. Like, look how awesome that is. And then also getting to hear a little bit more of like people's story and a little bit of a different perspective. And I think it's important to realize a manager isn't a dictator. And so you have to build that trust as well. I can't just tell people what to do. I have to work with them to hear them and motivate them to resolve conflicts. And if you derive value in that, being a manager is like a great way.
还记得当时这很困难吗？现在我们正在做 X、Y 和 Z。看，这多棒啊。此外，还能听到更多人们的故事和不同的视角。我认为重要的是要意识到经理不是独裁者。所以你必须建立信任。我不能只是告诉人们做什么。我必须与他们合作，倾听他们，激励他们解决冲突。如果你能从中获得价值，那么成为经理是一个很好的方式，
to have that be something that counts for your performance review. I've been in situations where I did a lot of that stuff, and I wasn't a manager. And when it came time to do my performance review, I got criticized because it was like, your technical contributions weren't as high as other individual contributors on the team. And I pointed out I do all this other stuff, you know, lubricating interpersonal conflict and resolving issues.
让这些工作计入你的绩效评估。我曾处于那种做了很多这类工作，但不是经理的情况。当绩效评估时，我受到了批评，因为他们说：“你的技术贡献不如团队中的其他个人贡献者。”我指出我做了所有这些其他事情，比如润滑人际冲突和解决问题。
They go, yeah, yeah, you do, but that's not your job. And it's like, oh, this is really frustrating. So in that moment, for me, being a individual contributor, and that was probably unique to that situation, but moving from individual contributor to manager allowed those things to be claimed on my performance reviews as part of my job. Yeah, I mean, this is sort of like tying a couple of things together,
他们说：“是的，你确实做了，但那不是你的工作。”这真的很令人沮丧。所以在那一刻，对我来说，作为个人贡献者——这可能对那个情况来说是独特的——但从个人贡献者转为经理，让我能够将这些事情作为我工作的一部分在绩效评估中提出。是的，这有点像把几件事联系在一起，
but this is why hopefully it's not always like the best coder who becomes the manager. So I've heard, I've had people say, I've never actually seen this in real life, but I agree with it if it was ever happened. Like, the single worst reason to become a manager is so you can win coding arguments.
这就是为什么最好的程序员并不总是成为经理的原因。我听说过，虽然我在现实生活中从未见过，但我同意这种说法：成为经理最糟糕的理由就是为了在代码争论中获胜。
Oh, God. I don't know if anyone who's ever thought that other than it's a big fun of it, but yeah, like this idea that, oh, you know,
天哪。我不知道除了开玩笑之外，还有谁会这么想，但确实，这种想法……
when I become the manager, then, you know, people will have to write in Haskell or people will have to, you know, do this video boosting idea that I have, That is like an unfathomably bad reason to become a manager.
“当我成为经理时，人们就必须用 Haskell 编写代码，或者人们就必须执行我那个视频加速的想法。”这是一个极其糟糕的成为经理的理由。
The reality is, is when you become a manager, you often lose a lot of your technical credibility. And that's just a fact. So that's the other edge of that sort. But to Patrick's point, the best relationships I have, work relationships I have are people who I use. used to manage. And especially, you know, people who, if you've managed them and then they've gone on and done amazing things, that's like the best relationship because, you know, because you were their manager and they have that kind of relationship with you, but you're not managing them anymore.
现实情况是，当你成为经理时，你往往会失去很多技术信誉。这是一个事实。这是硬币的另一面。但回到 Patrick 的观点，我拥有的最好的工作关系是我曾经管理过的人。特别是那些你管理过，然后他们去做了了不起的事情的人，那是最好的关系，因为你们曾经有那种管理关系，但现在不再管理他们了。
And especially if they are a rocket ship, they also have kind of like a peer relationship with you at the same time. And so you're getting kind of honesty but respect at the same time. It's an amazing relationship. And I have a friend who, I won't name her or anything, but she was on my team at Meta and then went on to OpenAI and these other companies. And I was talking with her last week. And it just was like one of the most fulfilling work conversations I've ever had.
特别是如果他们发展得很快，他们同时也会和你建立一种同僚关系。所以你既能得到诚实，又能得到尊重。这是一种很棒的关系。我有一位朋友，我不提她的名字，她曾在 Meta 我的团队里，后来去了 OpenAI 和其他公司。我上周和她聊天，那是我经历过的最充实的工作对话之一。
I mean, it was just such a joy. And it was such a joy and such an honor to have that kind of conversation, which I feel like you would miss out on that if you didn't go the manager route. Yeah. I think it is true, though, you know, you do get less time to code. It is less of an important thing when you do. And to be honest, I think it can be somewhat selfish to spend a lot of time coding and to make yourself a key person because if some issue comes up, it will take priority. If you have to go
那真是一种快乐。能进行那样的对话是一种快乐和荣幸，我觉得如果你不走管理路线，你就会错过这一点。是的。但我认为确实如此，你花在写代码上的时间变少了。当你写代码时，它也不那么重要了。老实说，我认为花大量时间写代码并让自己成为关键人物有时是自私的，因为如果出现问题，它会优先处理。如果你必须去
resolve a conflict or, you know, deliver slides for a presentation or whatever, and you're the key person on a key deliverable, that's a struggle. And it has to happen sometimes, but it's best avoided. So it is true. And to Jason's point, sometimes you kind of have to lose the argument with other people in order to like help the overall team. Whereas when you're an individual contributor, or you can kind of grind it out a little longer to try to win stuff. And then I will say, I think it is a touchy topic, but being a manager doesn't have to be forever.
解决冲突，或者为演示文稿准备幻灯片，或者其他什么，而你是关键交付物的关键人物，那会很挣扎。有时必须这样做，但最好避免。所以这是真的。正如 Jason 所说，有时你必须为了帮助整个团队而输掉争论。而当你作为个人贡献者时，你可以坚持更久一点来试图赢得争论。我想说，这是一个敏感话题，但成为经理不必是永久的。
Like there are options, especially when you're changing jobs, but even in the same job, although it's much harder to go back to being an individual contributor. So I do think as a manager, it's important to keep your skills brushed up, to keep making some progress in your coding abilities, or at least not letting them atrophy.
有很多选择，特别是在换工作时，甚至在同一份工作中也是如此，尽管回到个人贡献者角色要困难得多。所以我认为作为经理，保持技能更新、在编码能力上取得一些进展，或者至少不让它们退化是很重要的。
So, you know, make sure that that's something you're aware of. But it is difficult within the same team. I've seen it become very awkward before. But definitely like with switching teams, it's not something where if you become a manager, and often when you switch jobs, they don't want you to be a manager.
所以，确保你意识到这一点。但在同一个团队内确实很难。我以前见过这种情况变得非常尴尬。但绝对像换团队一样，如果你成为经理，通常当你换工作时，他们不希望你成为经理。
They want you to go back to being individual contributor, at least for a while, and then build up a team. And so I think being aware of that is something that can be a transition. Yeah. So, you know, transitioning back engineer is actually very, very common. It's one of these things that I don't even look at it as a
他们希望你回到个人贡献者角色，至少一段时间，然后再建立一个团队。所以我认为意识到这一点是一个过渡。是的。所以，转回工程师实际上非常非常普遍。这是我甚至不认为是一件
bad thing. As Patrick said, it'll often happen if you change companies, but even, you know, people who are ICs and have management experience, like bring a whole new dimension to the table. Yeah, I mean, my mind is kind of like racing with people's names, but I'm not going to say any of them. But I know people who, you know, went into management and it just, you know, it wasn't a good fit. Not for them as a person, but just the situation wasn't a good fit. You know, they inherited a team. The team had all these dysfunctions. And they switched to IC.
坏事的事情。正如 Patrick 所说，如果你换公司，这经常发生。而且，有管理经验的 IC 会带来全新的维度。是的，我的脑海里闪过很多人的名字，但我不会说出任何一个。但我认识一些人，他们进入了管理层，但并不合适。不是作为人本身不合适，而是情况不合适。他们接手了一个团队，团队有很多功能障碍。他们转回了 IC。
And that gave them, like, perspective and time to kind of reflect and everything. And I know one person in particular who now is, is like a really high up person. person at OpenAI, a different person and a director level. And I think that it's very common to go from manager to IC and then go back. And it happens all the time. It's just that there's, there's sort of like a stigma. I remember when I switched to manager, a bunch of people congratulated me. And it's just human nature, right?
这给了他们视角和时间来反思。我认识一个人，现在是 OpenAI 的高层，另一位是总监级别。我认为从经理转为 IC，然后再转回去是非常普遍的。这经常发生。只是有一种污名化。我记得当我转为经理时，很多人祝贺我。这是人性，对吧？
Like, I didn't get a promotion. I didn't get any more money. but it's human nature to think, oh, the managers have influence, and at least in tech, they don't really have that much influence, but the perception is still there. And so conversely,
我没有升职，也没有得到更多的钱，但人性使然，人们认为经理有影响力。至少在科技行业，他们并没有那么大的影响力，但这种看法依然存在。反之，
if you switch from being a manager to an I see, people won't want to really acknowledge that. And so people will often not make a big celebration about it or anything. And so you miss, It's like survivor bias. Like you miss all the times people switch to IC. And particularly you miss all the times people switch to IC and it was so much better.
如果你从经理转为 IC，人们不会真正承认这一点。所以人们通常不会为此大肆庆祝。所以你会错过——这就像幸存者偏差。你错过了所有人们转为 IC 的时刻。特别是你错过了所有人们转为 IC 后感觉好得多的时刻。
One of the most famous ones is So myth, the person who's the inventor of Pytorch. He led all of Pye Torch and then switched to an IC. This is years ago. But, you know, that enabled him to, you know, lead through influence and, you know, not have to do some of the management stuff that they found super draining for them. So it happens way more often. And I guess the point is, you know, you can switch to manager without it destroying your life if you hate it.
最著名的例子之一是 PyTorch 的发明者。他领导了整个 PyTorch，然后转为 IC。那是几年前的事了。但那使他能够通过影响力来领导，而不必做一些他觉得非常耗费精力的管理工作。所以这种情况发生得非常频繁。我想说的是，你可以尝试成为经理，如果讨厌它，也不会毁了你的生活。
So you could always try it, especially if you're kind of just, if it just works out for you to lead a team, maybe it's a team you started, maybe the manager left and you're kind of a natural replacement. It behooves you to give it a crack and then find out whether you like it or not. but do it knowing that it's a very, very different job and you're going to have to skill up in a new way. Well, hopefully that has been a useful discussion filled with opinions and hot takes.
所以你总是可以尝试一下，特别是如果领导团队对你来说顺理成章，也许是你发起的团队，也许经理离开了，你是自然的继任者。尝试一下并找出你是否喜欢它是值得的。但要带着这种认识：这是一份非常非常不同的工作，你必须以新的方式提升技能。好吧，希望这是一场充满观点和热点的有用讨论。
So I'm just kidding. Nothing too spicy. Nothing too spicy. That wasn't too bad. I feel like it was pretty positive overall. Well, all right, this is great. I feel like this is, I can't remember who recommended this, but this is a really solid topic.
开个玩笑。没什么太辛辣的。没什么太辛辣的。还不算太糟。我觉得整体还是挺积极的。好吧，这很棒。我觉得这是一个非常扎实的话题，我不记得是谁推荐的了。
Thank you out there. Thanks to the Discord, a lot of happy Thanksgiving. in the Discord, which is really cool to see. And we will catch you all next time. Music by Eric Barndollar. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share-A-Like 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work,
谢谢大家。感谢 Discord，Discord 里有很多感恩节快乐的祝福，这真的很酷。我们下次再见。音乐由 Eric Barndollar 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，
to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share like and kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
进行重混、改编，但必须注明 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。